all right good morning welcome to
Edna today is pension bills number one
all of these bills will be going to
subcommittee unless something
extraordinary happens and so M
representative Simon will be leading the
sub Comm committee and that's where all
the details will be beaten
out
uh recognize to of the sponsors
representative lean and representative
Maguire thank you madam chair and I'm
glad to have representative Dan Maguire
sitting to my left uh we often joke in
finance that he's our professor and goto
guy with retirement issues so it's good
to have him there but I think that has
something to do with who he commutes
with to conquer it for perhaps but I do
have a couple of handouts uh one is the
report of the retirement
commission uh and also the LBA did a
nice comparison there's been some
discussion about what you had here last
year
436 and so I have a comparison between
what this bill does and um okay thanks
Dan excellent those are those are very
useful items and I'm sure we will study
them
well I wrote the report so I know about
that one all
right you also have a document there
from Marty Carlin from the retirement
system I I think it's one of the best
documents I've ever seen it breaks
things down into a very understandable
um or gives you an idea what six 1646 or
47 sorry what 647 does and essentially
um as I think all of you know that
there's been a group of people since uh
more than a decade ago that had their
benefits changed there are several
different tiers as you'll see on the
document Marty gave you were provided
where you have it's a second page by the
way um of that document what this bill
does and what again 1647 does is simply
brings everybody to the same level the
uh multiplier 2.5 once you're vested uh
after 10 years everybody falls into the
2.5 multiplier and you'll see on the top
of the page above 10 years there are all
these different
tiers um until you get over to tier C
which is anybody that's been hired after
71 11 they have a multiplier of two and
again this bill treats everybody the
same after 10 years of vesting which I
think is a fairness issue and it's
something that representative Maguire
Dan Maguire and I have looked to uh
tackle for years and I know Dan would
like to probably say something because
he's been very much involv I'm sorry Dan
Maguire has been very much involved in
this and has pushed hard for us to bring
everybody to um the same standard if you
will thank you and thank you committee
um so this bill is the successor to to
House Bill 436 if you remember House
Bill 436 that was the one that um for
the middle group of people that were um
employed on uh July 1st uh 2011 uh but
not yet vested they had their
pension um reduced considerably the 2
and a half% multiplier became 2% and
there were other changes so 436 was the
bill that restored essentially all those
other
changes um it was very expensive it was
uh um going to be um $25 million a year
for 10 years something like that and so
um it passed the house it passed your
committee quite strongly it passed the
house strongly we put it it came to our
part of the um finance committee we
argued over it I personally thought that
it was too expensive and I wanted
something like
1647 um but I was shouted down and we
put it in the budget um as part of
another compromise dealing with other
other parts of the budget we sent it
over to the Senate they ripped it out of
the budget okay and instead they put in
this
commission um uh a couple of you here
are members of this commission but they
put in a commission to study the whole
situation the commission you now have
the report and and their recommendation
was what is now
1647 it's much cheaper it's more like 55
million now and and there's some ongoing
because because you know people who are
ongoing will have a will have a better
pension so there's some ongoing cost but
but to catch us up sort of is is 55
million not 250 million and um so and I
I personally think this is very fair
this is in fact very similar to what I
was arguing for when we were doing the
budget um but but uh as um
representative Lehman mentioned um this
conc the main changes here are on the
multiplier only not on all the ancillary
stuff not on the definition of income or
the definition of service and you know
all that kind of stuff is is not in here
and I think appropriately um but it's
it's really about the
multiplier so um I personally think uh
you know this bill the thing we have to
have in the back of our mind is what can
we get through you know getting through
the house hopefully is not a big deal or
not too complicated but but through the
entire process and having the governor
sign it you know that's where we've been
running into roadblocks on this kind of
thing and so um we have to be careful
not to ask for too much in order to push
it through so thank you are there any
questions for representative
leean representative O'Brien good
morning thank you good morning Madame
chair how are you uh
Representatives um when this bill was uh
when the pension system was originally
changed and I think uh off the top of my
head 2011 around within that time frame
so there's been this cost of deduction
everything has been around since 2011
when you ran the numbers and just I
think for the new members of this
committee did anybody focus on how much
money the state was actually saved and
you know I'm not looking looking for a
definition if it was a savings if we
have to pay back at this particular time
for what I call this mistake you may not
but the thing is the state did receive a
benefit where municipalities had a step
forward for a long period of time and I
just wonder if that number is wholly
recognized I yeah sure so yes thank you
for the question representative um
it's it's very hard to answer that
question because there were many changes
made as I said not just to the
multiplier but there were changes made
to the definitions the ages all kinds of
other things some changes were made for
group one and group two some changes
were made just for group two um and then
you talk about savings to the state um
there were was also as you know the
state used to pay municipalities a
significant part of pension costs that
went away but on the other hand because
of those changes in the numbers
municipalities saved a lot right so one
point I should make is the 55 million
we're
spending benefits mostly
municipalities right the the bulk of
group two employees work for
municipalities they don't work for the
state it's something like uh 4 to1 or
five to one something like that the ones
in this work for the state mostly work
for the Department of
Corrections um and and also state
troopers but but but municipalities
almost all firefighters work for
municipality and and most police so
representative O'Brien to respond to
that during the budget negotiations in
2011 the savings from the pension P from
changes to the pension system will well
recognize
in resolving the billion doll shortfall
we faced that year which I believe you
remember fighting
about follow followup thank you madam
chair for the followup uh one of the
things that is uh highlight and as you
know representative Maguire and
representative leechman uh I wear two
hats and a helmet you know being a
former firefighter but the other hat
that I where is uh vice president of the
board of alderman in nashar and one of
the issues and it's really truly an
issue of uh you know keeping retaining
you know hiring and retaining new so I
know you can't forecast you haven't got
the crystal ball or neither do I but how
do you feel this bill would help in that
those two particular
areas okay
[Music]
thank you for the question one of the
things we looked at on the retirement
commission as the chair pointed out uh
she served on the commission along with
myself is a retention issue and it was
felt that by adding this additional
retention tool by saying that everybody
was treated the same and increasing the
multiplier by 2.5 that would help and
people's decision one to stay longer
with the state and maybe come to work
for the state
thank you madam chair representative
groa thank you this question is for
either one of you does um house bill um
1647 addressed the recommendations from
the um retirement
commission if you look inside the
document I handed out from the
retirement commission there's a list of
items that U the commission suggested
move forward and not all of these were
recommended unanimously this particular
item was an 8 to6 vote to support this
but I think it's on the second or third
page it points out what items should be
brought forward through legislation and
I was asked to bring this particular
item
forward follow
up and the $55 million fiscal note is to
be paid by the state the state and it
brings everybody up to date so that from
then on it becomes the responsibility of
the state and municipalities correct
that's correct thank
you okay goie you have no anyone else
representative
laus um I see there's not a fiscal note
yet so I just
uh uh want to verify that the 55 million
covers uh the entire cost of I believe
Backus there is in fact a fiscal note
that wasn't included in in the bill that
you got but it some people haven't ah
okay thank you I just want what I'm
asking is um is there any change to the
unfunded liability as a result would
there be as a result of passing
this so I believe the answer is no okay
um it's 50 it's actually closer to 56
million
55.9 but but the answer is no but there
is extra cost to munici both the state
and municip IP alties the state about a
million dollars a year and
municipalities about four ongoing okay
thank
you represent gold thank you madam chair
I just wanted to thank you on behalf of
the municipalities that I um represent
Warner Bradford and Haner and especially
a shout out to Haner I will support this
thank you thank you representative Simon
thank you madam chair um just looking at
the estimated political subdivision
impact uh on the fiscal note uh year
2026 is4 million
90,000 and uh 2027 is $4.2 million uh
I'm assuming that's an estimate that's
just based on the potential increase in
salaries that is going to be covered
under the plan is that correct yes um uh
Mr Carlin I think prepared this you can
ask him specific Mr Carlin will be the
next speaker very well thank you madam
chair okay any other questions for the
sponsors all right thank you very much
thank you may I point out one sort of
technical thing if you if you don't mind
um go
ahead there's there's what I think is a
poor drafting in the bill um on page uh
three line
18 and also
um I think this there's the same thing
thing uh I think there's the same thing
somewhere else but um let's look at page
three line
18 um it says uh maximum number of years
not in excess and it used to say 40 and
a half and now it has this phrase limits
under such and such if you look in your
new blue
book in this uh 100 a colon
6-a um it doesn't there's no there's no
years in that right so so it's it's
really confusing to say the number of
years is not in excess of that section
when there's no years in that section
right so I I would
suggest you you simply re you can you
can safely remove this this whole phrase
um because because that section the
section it refers to is the one that
limits that has an overall raw limit on
a pension of 85% of of the maximum
salary or some some amount some I don't
know if it's $100,000 120,000 or
something um that's what that section
does and that section will apply whether
this is written here or not so to me
it's simpler you could just if you're
making an amendment to this uh cross
that out and I think it it appears in a
second place as well so probably under
normal retirement since the section
you're quoting deal with disability
retirement Madam chair but anyway we'll
we'll look at that in
subcommittee now Madam chair you can see
why we affectionately call
Representative DM Maguire the professor
so yes thank
you all right other questions thank you
gentlemen Mr
Carlin
uh thank you Madame chair for the record
Marty Carlin representing the New
Hampshire retirement system uh the
retirement system doesn't have a
position on the bill we consider it a
policy matter left to the
legislature um the previous speakers
referenced the handout uh that I
provided to the committee there are some
extras on the table if they haven't all
been taken yet um if basically as as a
brief walk through
this just this handout describes the
change which is to the benefit
multiplier there there are three
components that go into calculating a
pension it's you how long you've worked
months and years your average final
compensation either on a high three or a
high five um average with some some
other uh caps within that in the statute
uh and this benefit multiplier which is
basically you think of it as an acral
rate every year you work you're
recruiting you know 2.1 2.2% of your
ultimately your AFC when you retire so
this bill changes the multiplier it does
not change the average final
compensation calculation nor the
definition of earnable compensation what
goes into that AFC calculation so a
house bill uh 436 last year did changed
all three in different ways so this this
is more focused specifically on the
multiplier that's one of the reasons
that it's less costly even though it
affects more people um so the chart
under the background heading just shows
the um the minimum age in service
requirements for group two retirement uh
for folks who weren't vested prior to
January 1st of 2012 uh plus the
multiplier that they currently have
under the statute and what the proposal
would uh Grant to those tiers after 10
years um we started referring refering
to the groups both group one and group
two as tiers uh last year just because
it was kind of a mouthful to say uh
member was in service prior to 71 of 11
and not vested prior to 11 one of 12 but
the that that nomenclature isn't in the
statute it's the long terms in there but
just for shorthand uh we went to that so
uh and on this document we don't break
it down typically this much tier B 432
and one but there are steps on the
ladder of that transition table for
those tier B members um so that just
shows all of the group The the
membership tiers affected by this
proposal as a count over on the far
right hand side um again just just for
scale to look at that and on page two is
a summary of the Actuarial analysis
under Financial
considerations um earlier question which
representative McGuire correctly
answered was the 55.9 million general
fund appropriation uh included in this
bill currently would uh cover the
projected unfunded liability for this
change um there is also a future ongoing
normal cost is what it's referred to the
cost of benefits as as they acrew you
know in the years that people work going
forward that's would increase uh the
group two police and fire employer rates
by a little bit under 1% of pay uh
beginning in fiscal 26 they were already
in the 2425 rates were certified a
couple years ago you know that cake is
baked so it won't start showing up in
the rates until uh July 1 of
um and you know we also are going to
have some programming costs associated
with that but that's pretty much goes
without saying for any change so um and
then the third page is the chart uh
representative leean um referred to this
is something we prepared for the uh
Commission uh in the fall to look at
it's just an illustration just showing
you know for what year someone's working
what their multiplier is under the
proposal so just just for quick
illustration if you look at the column
that says tier B2 those are members who
I had four more than four but less than
six years as of one one of 12 and their
uh minimum age in service is 48 with 23
years of service and their multiplier
currently is 2.2% for each year they
worked so that person would acrew
2.2% per year 22% of their ASC in their
first 10 years and then for the
remaining years in their career the
acral would be at
2.5% so in that
um uh situation that would if somebody
worked the minimum 23 years it would
increase their percentage the multiplier
you know 23 years time 2.2 is
50.6%
uh and it's in with 10 years at 2.2 and
13 years at 2.5 it becomes 54.5% of your
AFC so so this would represent a a
benefit increase um you know for all
members including those in tier C which
were folks hired after 7 one of 11 in
future
hires um again i' lot to unpack here but
I'd be glad to answer any questions the
committee would have
thank you for all this valuable
information representative
O'Brien thank you madam chair uh Mr
Colin to refer back I I just wonder if
there's anywhere that uh through
research or whatever is that a number
that is easy to grab on what I'm talking
about since 2011 until now
municipalities municipalities had born
from originally 30 some odd percent 35%
down to zero what was the cost savings
to the state on that and so in other
words to say this is extra money excuse
me representative
[Music]
O'Brien we're I do not want to debate
the question of who pays what I am
trying we're trying to discover the
entire cost to the state and the
municipalities and the employees and the
benefits to them the distribution of who
PID what is something I don't think we
need to debate here yeah uh as Madam
chair you always take the edge off thank
you very much I much appreciate there's
a separate bill on that you'll get your
chance but Madam chair would it be fair
for me what I'm searching for is that
particular number I believe you should
address that on House Bill
1279 is specifically about who pays what
share of what thank you madam chair
sorry any other questions well we got Mr
Carlin
here all right thank you very much I'm
amazed thank you madam chair all right
um Mr Brian
will and
then Mr Campo who was both these people
were members of the
commission
good morning thank you madam chair
members of the committee uh I'd like to
thank representative Dan McGuire and
representative leechman um for uh kind
of setting the uh setting the tone here
and reminding everyone about House Bill
436 I won't recap that they did a fine
job uh painting the picture of last
session where we had um overwhelming
support from not only this committee but
the entire house uh to restore pension
benefits lost from 2011 um um
unfortunately as we we know that was
removed uh by the Senate and replaced
with the retirement benefits commission
which I was lucky enough to be able to
serve on uh as the clerk I believe that
the commission um came forward with some
very productive dialogue and we were
able to provide a lot of uh answers to a
lot of questions as to what the problem
is and how we got here um I wish I could
sit before you and tell you today that
the Recruitment and Retention issues uh
have been solved or even been improved
since last year I can tell you that is
uh not the case in fact just the
opposite um we continue to uh struggle
to find Personnel to want to work in
these Public Safety professions um and
retirement is cited as one of those um
Number One issues as to why we cannot
recruit nor
retain uh firefighters in the state of
New
Hampshire when we talked about this
issue in the commission uh there was a
lot of back and forth and we eventually
got to a point where it was uh
determined that we should be focusing
holistically on improving the
Recruitment and Retention crisis in our
state and not hyperfocusing on one group
of
individuals while we believed that house
bill
436 Still Remains The Fix to one uh
catastrophic issue in our state with
pension um we we decided to take the
lead from those in the room that wanted
to uh affect more change with more
members and with that we feel that we
came to a fair compromise and that is
the provisions that are here in uh
before us in House Bill
1647 uh we believe taking a look at the
entire picture with the members in our
state uh encouraging those to want to
come into public service and Public
Safety in our state by increasing a
benefit uh for all um restoring for some
and increasing for others uh I think
this is a huge step forward for the
State of New Hampshire um I'm certain
that this committee will will support it
similar to uh your support of House Bill
436 uh I look forward to increased
discussions on this and I look forward
to uh getting this through and and again
taking a step forward on retirement in
our state thank you madam chair I'd be
happy to answer any questions I've also
submitted some written testimony
excellent are there any questions
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so I take
it your earlier reference you will be
participating with the
subcommittee yes absolutely thanks okay
any other questions
excellent job thank you thank you Mr
Campo good morning Madam chair and
committee my name is Frank Campo I'm a
sergeant with the state police I also
serve as a president of the Troopers
Association I'd like to start off by
just thanking this committee for their
hard work on house build 436 last year
it passed overwhelmingly in the house
unfortunately it didn't uh didn't pass
through the Senate um like to talk just
a little bit to start here with uh the
retention issues that specifically we're
having with the state police I think
it's no secret uh at the beginning of
2023 the state police had approximately
a 20% vacancy rate uh but during 2023 we
had one of our best hiring years ever
which was um you know very fantastic but
unfortunately here we are at the
beginning beginning of 2024 and we're
still at the same vacancy rate you know
what does that mean as many people that
we were able to bring in last year
that's the same amount of people that
left um in this trend it just it can't
keep it can't continue we can't keep
recycling experienced Troopers for
inexperienced ones we are the back stop
of law enforcement in this state we
investigate the majority of the
homicides we investigate all officer
involved shootings our SWAT team our K9
team our crash analysis reconstruction
team uh are responding to more more
calls than ever um there was a need to
create a northern border Alliance and
that fell on the state police to manage
as well um something something needs to
change uh last year we saw a trend of
more experience Troopers leaving for
other endeavors and that Trend continues
today but we're also seeing a trend of
our younger Troopers leaving as well you
know since the changes in 2012 New
Hampshire no longer has a competitive uh
pension benefit that coupled with better
opportun unities in the private sector
or federal government makes it um almost
impossible for us to retain our
talent the provisions in HB 1647 are a
huge step in the right direction it not
only addresses issues we're facing for
the folks in the middle te it also um
addresses issues that we're facing with
those in TRC as well um this bill just
makes sense it would increase an
employees multiplier the longer he or
she remains in active service and that's
exactly what we need an incentive to
keep our people um in the job here and
yes this bill will cost money but you
know what is the cost of of doing
nothing here um so for these reasons I
would hope that this committee would
support this bill I'm happy to answer
any questions if anybody has any thank
you are there any questions
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair same
question as the previous witness you'll
be available for the subcommittee yes
sir thank you okay else represent PTI
thank you madam chair um just my
question to you is about the
turnover how is it trending in terms of
losing experienced and now you're saying
retention of new Hye also do you have a
data for
the last few years that's turn over how
it's affecting Recruitment and Retention
um I'm I'm not sure if I'd be able to
explain how it's affecting the turn was
affecting Recruitment and Retention but
I can certainly get the numbers um for
this committee and I can email them to
you um as soon as I can get them within
the next probably a few days thank you
thank you anyone
else all right thank you very much thank
you art
bodri good morning Madam chair I wish
you all a Happy New Year um Madam
chairman members of the committee my
name is bodri I represent the New
Hampshire State permanent firefighters
retirement Association and I'm here in
favor of this of House Bill
1647 uh I would like to Echo uh what
Brian stated um this bill helps but it's
not a it's not a true fix um 4 436 was a
true fix for those members that were not
vested as of January 2012 this is a
Band-Aid approach to fixing a bigger
problem um it does help out uh for for
new hires after um January of 2012 by
giving them the 2 and a half% after 10
years so that should help a little bit
on on retention uh but as far as
recruitment um it's still the first 10
years are still at 2% um and when you
look at group one and group two uh group
group one benefits are almost uh
probably even better than group two now
because they get Social Security and and
group two doesn't and they get their
benefit is calculated at
1.67% and and police and fire is at 2%
so we're risking our life every day when
we go out there for small percentage
over what a person that doesn't have to
risk their life um is doing so that is a
concern um and 436 would have been it
did pass this committee it passed the
house unfortunately the Senate uh didn't
buy into it um which is a mistake
because uh there's been members of the
legislature to say we don't want bills
coming in every year well the only way
you're going to fix it is if 436 were to
pass that fixed the problem that
originally happened back in
2011 um and with that I would answer any
questions thank you very much are there
any
questions no thank you and I'm sure
we'll have your help at the subcommittee
yes thank you okay John selli
good
morning uh I'd like to take this
opportunity uh to thank the Edna
committee for their hard work last year
uh a little bit about myself uh I'm
currently a sergeant with the Nashville
Police Department I've been there for
the last 16 years I'm also 29
years
gotcha uh I've been in law enforcement
for 29 years my first 13 te were spent
in Massachusetts um I'm currently here
representing the New Hampshire Police
Association I'm the treasurer for that
organization I'm also the president of
the supervisor's Union for the
nationville police department uh it was
unfortunate that house bill 436 didn't
pass last year uh but I believe House
Bill 1647 is a step in the right
direction um into you know the nhpa
whole hardly agrees with and supports
that decision that the retirement
commission put
forward to outline I think what our
biggest retention and recruitment
problems are is our number one
competitor for law enforcement and
firefighters is Massachusetts and when
we compare the two Retirement Systems we
are not even in the same ballpark
anymore uh Massachusetts if you compare
apples to apples uh you need to do a
32ye career after 32 years you'll get an
80% pension of your salary after 32
years in New Hampshire you're going to
get a 64% pension of your salary
Massachusetts also offers uh uh health
care benefits at 80 to 90% we offer zero
I can tell you from working in the
recruiting division at the Nashville
Police Department I heard numerous times
that they were choosing Massachusetts
over us because of the pension system
alone I came here like I said 16 years
ago because New Hampshire had a great
reputation for law enforcement they had
a great retirement and then when I came
here that was taken away from us and now
I'm not seeing the same level of people
coming to our great state to work here
and we're not able to recruit anymore
and I'm available for any questions
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee representative laus
thank you um not sure I heard the
numbers uh the there was a percentage of
uh I assume salary that uh people would
uh get in retirement Mass versus New
Hampshire what were those so to compare
years of service uh 32 years of service
in Massachusetts to retire at 80% of
your salary in ma uh New Hampshire is
50% uh I'm sorry 64% after the same
amount of time okay thank
you
okay thank you very much thank
you SE
regasa
thank you madam chair for the
opportunity to speak my name is sauras I
a chief provision prol
officer excuse would you turn your the
microphone on can you hear me there you
go thank you my name is saasa I'm a
chief provision par officer with the
state of New Hampshire I'm also the
president of the New Hampshire probation
parl Command Staff Union for the
probation parl officers I've been
employed by the state of shamire for the
past 22 years additionally I'm an arank
Professor with sou New Hampshire
University in the criminal justice
department um so I am here to speak in
support of the house bill
1647 uh but I'm not supporting the bill
because the
bill uh
is as as this bill is the only solution
this bill is not the solution for the
Recruitment and Retention issue we have
in this state but rather it would take
the current members in much better
avenues that where they are at um as you
heard from the other group two law
enforcement officers and firefighters
our state is in a very compromised
position where we're losing public
service employees to other states we're
losing them because we are not
compartible in a compartible
market uh back in
2012 the retirement system has changed
Al questionable if it was necessary or
not but the damage that has left is
impacting us every single day uh my
agent my division is uh part of
Department of Correction as you all uh
heard last year
uh we are at 50% uh vacancy
rate uh we had the National Guard
respond and cover post at the prison in
two different occasions last year and
that situation has gotten worse not
better so the challenge we're having is
it's not only Recruitment and yes as
representative McGuire indicated that
this is more of a retention Bill to keep
those who are in the service so we don't
lose them we're not recruiting I uh last
year I had asked my students a question
how many of them were prepared to join
the public service here in the state of
New Hampshire out of a large group of
student I had two people who are willing
to join the service in the state service
so we're losing the young graduate from
college we're losing a season
experienced officers who had actually
work for this state because they have a
bad taste in their mouth
uh they're disheartened because we
changed their condition of employment
after they were hired and served the
state 9 years and 11 months because they
didn't have 10 years they were not
keeping what they were promised at the
time of hire
so uh I uh commend any bill that promote
some form of change in the retirement
we're not Computing we're not
recruiting and I am concerned about the
public safety in the future and uh I
think this bill as uh representative
Maguire stated that 436 was killed
because it was expensive that is the
bill that I would like to see in the
future and you'll continue to see me
coming here and testifying in any bill
for any build to change the current
conditions because it's unsafe it is a
bad condition we are in but uh I will
support the spill because it is a change
and will be able to help us to retain uh
who we have
with that I will take any question you
may have for me thank you very much are
there any
questions I don't see any but thank you
for your testimony thank you madam
CH is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 1647
representative
Pearson
do we have do we even have any pink
cards here because I don't see any on
the
table thank
you thank you madam chair thank you
members of Edna a committee I serve two
terms on for the record I'm
Representative Steve Pearson Rockingham
District 13 in Dairy I'm a lieutenant
with the city of Manchester fire
department I'm a member of group two and
I am a person who was caught up in this
colossal mess in
2011 just a couple things the the folks
that spoke before did an eloquent job
they uh they covered pretty much the
problem it's it's not a surprise now we
we've been talking about this for years
so I'm not going to reiterate any of
that but I do just want to cover two
things um so there's some
clarity and this is a repetitive part of
what was said I want to make sure that
you that is understood that this is a
partial fix this is not the fix I
appreciate that so far that is this has
not been referred to as the fix but I
want to make sure that that ver does not
end up in the vernacular here because
that would not be an accurate
statement one of the things
that and I support
1647 but I just want to point out two
things as as far as what this changes
the first one is the folks that were
affected the most the folks that had
eight nine 10 years into a career when
these changes occurred are actually
going to benefit the least from this
bill now we look at this
holistically it's not always just about
one group or another or
about one group being pitted against
another and that's why I support this
legislation but I do want to point that
part of it out the second thing is that
I don't want to see this bill
miscategorized as something that was
that will now retain people to work
beyond their minimum Service
retirement because this legislation just
restores things back to the way they
were it doesn't do anything beyond that
and one of the factors here financially
in the pension system is the longer an
employee works the better it is for the
system because that employee is now
contributing out of their paycheck and
not drawing a pension
benefit
so I hope that we don't see this
categorized in any way as being
something that incentivizes people to
work longer we could have done that you
and legislation could be brought forward
to to incentivize and hang that carrot
out there but that this is not it this
just puts things back to where they
were in as far as the multiplier Beyond
10 years and that's uh that's all I'm
going to touch on with this thank you
you take some questions absolutely
representative
sh thank you madam chair thank you
representative Pearson um for your
perspective on this I'm sure you're
aware as this committee is aware that
the folks that you mentioned that had
nine or 10 years of service in when the
uh change occurred have now worked an
additional 10 to 11 years and are
probably close to
retirement uh do you have any kind of
idea how many of those folks are still
on the job or have they just given up
and left so so as far as a hard number
that's something that would be better
directed towards a retirement system
they they can provide you hard numbers
but I can tell you that um we
surprisingly have
seen folks leaving that have just gotten
to the point where they're not willing
to wait anymore because they've been
asked to wait and give the legislature
the opportunity to do its job
and fix
this and at some point they just they
can't wait any longer and they have to
go now
unfortunately the with the way things
work is when you retire in the New
Hampshire retirement system your pension
is set that's it so to make a a fix for
someone that retired last
month they're they're out you know that
barring a a
constitutional violation you're not
going to see any retroactive changes so
so that we have seen that we have seen
folks that have have held on a little
bit longer especially on the law
enforcement side and have just finally
worn out frankly this is these jobs are
very physically demanding and and they
just can't
continue I will mention that of the
bills in question the affected
group is has gone down from 1800 and
some odd to 1650 or so over the course
of this session so
there these people are eligible to
retire and many of them are choosing to
do so so the only other thing I'd like
to say Madam chair you were the the
chair of the of the um commission um the
only the only thing I would I'd like to
address there is I would have liked to
seen opportunity for that commission to
take some testimony from the
public we which which just didn't Happ
yes I understand that you mentioned it
at the time I thought we had enough
representatives of the public on the
commission that that might not have been
as NE as necessary as it is in the
legislature so that's that's you know I
like I said I do appreciate the
commission's work on this I was I had
attended a fair number and and took
advantage of the opportunity of
technology that we have today to to
watch the rest of them remotely
so all right thank you very much for
your testimony any other
questions thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on 164
s introduce yourself
please good morning thank you for your
time my name is Frank sorko I'm a PE and
probation officer for the State of New
Hampshire I work out of the Manchester
office um I'm also the uh president of
the New Hampshire parole probation
officers Association and I am the
secretary for the New Hampshire Police
Association I don't want to repeat what
everyone said especially following uh
representative Pearson but I just want
to um Express the plle officers and uh I
can't speak for the Corrections Officers
but I do work with them I work to help
at the prisons and uh I think uh
Corrections and especially the parole
officers support this bill it's a step
in the right direction I think uh 436
last year was the fix but this is
definitely the uh step in the right
direction thank you thank you any
questions all right thank you very much
thank
you all right anyone
else seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
1647 and open the hearing on House Bill
1653 and and Mr Carlin we don't have a
sponsor here so
uh if you're going to to if you wish to
speak representative you should put a
card in so we know you want to
speak
all
thank
you okay
fine yes all right we've got your card
for this bill representative
cra
thank you for recog out recognizing us
out in the crowd there um
1653 as presented is uh well let me just
speak earlier how we talked about
1647 and uh as everybody knows I think
in this room that uh the changes that
were made in 200 uh1 and 11 was made and
there was seven different things that
were changed to the people that were
already working uh I'm in favor of 1647
I know I not supposed to talk about that
now but that did fix part of the problem
uh now we're talking about uh these two
new bills
1653 also takes care of one piece of
that um seven changes that were made
back 10 years ago 11 years
ago want to go into detail I can go into
detail
sure detail I'm the detail guy I guess
so specifically what this does is it
separates out group one and group two as
far as the as far as the earnable
compensation definition the definition
uh used to exist the same for both
groups and what we found in the early
stages of 436 last year was that uh
there were some unintended consequences
when when that bill in its original
incarn was brought forward um as it made
changes to a group that we did not
intend to
change so in order to properly do that
within the the definition section of RSA
100a you would have to separate this out
now of course when you look at a bill
everything that's in bold is
new so I want to go over what's actually
new and what's actually just not just a
repeat right because it's created a new
paragraph but it's verbatim language
with the
exception of line 20 and 21 that is the
only
difference everything else is the same
as it exists under current law so line
20 and 21 what that does is it
says
that any member hired before July 1 of
2011 which was sort of that Line in the
Sand that that we have for uh changes
for the most part
shall have their overtime pay included
as their base pay that is what the law
stated when they were hired we had a
very simple calculation in those days
you could actually do it on a postcard
it was a it was a conglomeration of the
various aspects of your of your J salary
your
overtime detail pay if that was
something that was involved in in your
profession in group two and they simply
added that up and divided by three it
was it was fairly simple
so when that started to get chopped up
and moved and some things were removed
and the legislature decided to to look
at some of the aspects of what was
included and not
included that became a more complicated
formula so what this does is it
basically takes overtime pay and just
overtime pay not detail pay not no
incentives no other type of pay just
overtime pay and brings it back into
base salary
so when you're working
overtime and and it's kind of funny to
to think of it in this terms but if I'm
if I'm working a shift on Tuesday and
it's my regular
shift that
becomes the base pay of my pension
calculation but if I work on
Wednesday because we have a vacancy and
they need someone I'm doing the exact
same job doing the exact same thing that
is now treated
differently and I the pecul famar it of
that is is something that causes most
people to to raise an eyebrow and to try
to understand how when I did the exact
same thing I did yesterday it's not
treated the same way now
overtime in the past has been somewhat
of a well at one point it was a dirty
word in municipalities but the reality
of today is that the the total
compensation package that's given to a
Municipal Employee is broken up between
a salary and and the benefit part of it
the benefit part of that has now
exceeded the salary part unfortunately
due to healthare costs and and other
things so what you're seeing now is
you're seeing an increase use of
overtime because it's actually cheaper
for the municipality to fill a shift on
a fairly regular basis with overtime
than it is to hire another human who now
has to get dental benefits and health
benefits and vacation time and all of
that that that's a phenomenon that's
relatively recent so as we move forward
and we see this this being used as a
costs
measure in some
cases let's let's kind of scale this
back and say okay if that's really how
how things are going and and we're
asking these people to do the same exact
job on Wednesday they did on Tuesday
should that not just be treated the same
that's that's the the concept and the
premise of this idea um
and like I said despite all the the
boldface type literally the difference
is lines 20 and
21 thank you representative Pearson
representative Schmidt and then
laus thank you madam chair morning
representative so when you're giving an
exam the the example you gave you're not
talking about that your regular job is
on Tuesday and occasionally you're doing
the same job filling in for a needed uh
shift on Wednesday this week you're
talking about every week not or what is
the exact situation so in the sense of
you know when overtime opportunities for
for most agencies are are done in a fair
and Equitable way so I may not be able
to work Wednesday I may be up here but
someone else is going to be given the
opportunity to fill that necessary shift
in so it's not it's it's not that it's a
it's a it's a predictable and constant
thing um it may be a constant thing in
the sense of the of them using that
tactic to to lower cost for that shift
but those that fill that in would be
would be taken from a pool and and
that's equitably discharged so that it
wouldn't be a single person that would
do would do
that followup but if they're doing it
effectively every week not necessarily
with you sometimes it's with your
colleague there or another one of the
employees uh but there but that opening
is there every week and until they and
are is the um municipality trying to
hire somebody to F to permanently fill
that slot they just can't so they're
using you this week and somebody else
two weeks down and so forth sure you'll
see that in both ways you you'll see the
the the tactic of delaying bringing on a
full-time person to to lower costs in
the short term and in some cases they're
begging literally begging for someone to
fill that slot and they can't find them
follow and and the uh and this the cost
savings is not in the salary because
they're paying somebody to do that the
cost savings is the benefits that don't
have to be expanded in terms of the cost
to the municipality correct a a person
that works an overtime shift doesn't get
extra Dental right you know what I mean
they don't get the one one more Crown
issue to them in the course of their
their time those things are fairly
fairly fixed to the person so that
that's where you see substantial savings
good are you going to be available for
the sub committee as well try thank you
representative laus thank you so um I'm
trying to understand the effect of this
you're talking about uh people now who
have to work overtime and they have
questions about why that overtime isn't
included in their uh pension
calculations but the two lines you
mentioned uh say it appears to only
affect members hired before July 1 2011
that is correct so are let's say
somebody's hired you know a year was
hired a year ago MH are they currently
getting um their overtime included in
their pension they are but it is
calculated in a much different
manner now I I've I've stated this in
front of Edna many times the legislature
has the
right and I will defend that right to
modify the system for new
hires right so what what I what I argue
that this legislature cannot do is
retroactively modify things and that's
what this fixes is the folks who who
were retroactively
altered uh followup followup so if I
understand correctly this isn't going
to affect anybody who's working now
unless they were hired before their date
that's correct and um and you said it's
it's handled very differently so how is
overtime pay handled as far as
Retirement currently so if you were
hired today what they would do is they
would run that over your entire career
so if you did a for easy math a 20-year
career actually you can't do a 20 I
would even say that you can't even do a
20-year career right now so a 30-year
career which is which will be is the
becoming the average for the Young Folks
now if you do a 30-year career they will
take the the entire run of your overtime
over that 30 years and then run it
through a
formula which is I suppose fantastic if
you don't get deployed it's yes the it's
a fairly complex calculation that is
designed to not penalize people who
consistently work overtime and some
people do but not allow individuals to
work a lot of overtime in their last few
years to artificially bump up their
salary which which under under this
would be extraordinarily difficult to do
because that average is a under in that
retroactively done in 2009 is a
seven-year average you can't just hit
the street for one year and overly
inflate this is this is done over a
seven-year average anyway all right
thank you okay representative O'Brien
you had a question uh thank you um Madam
chair and I'm going to attempt just to
help
clarify for some of the new people uh
some of within a lot of the
overtime and I hate using the term
overtime because in a lot of communities
it's not not it's actually natural we
affectionally call it like shift
coverage because it's not time and a
half and that's because of the Garcia
decision and we could discuss that at a
later date but the thing is by certain
type of communities you sign the list
you get the overtime it's your
responsibility to get a replacement to
do it it it's not uh like you say no
refusal so in other words you get for
Christmas day you're working baby you
know and uh so is that true in a lot of
the communities
here the city of Nashua which is what
you're referring to because I recognize
that that
operational method that Nasa uses um is
not standardized
Statewide there is no Statewide standard
I can tell you as an example in the city
of Manchester it's simply done using a a
third party contractor that tracks hours
and he who hath the least or she we have
SE several females on mest fire he he or
she who hath the least gets the first
opportunity that is done so it's an
inequitable way and it also prevents a
single individual from cranking up their
overtime because it is distributed
equitably that is a spiking protection
that the city of Manchester
uses thank you representative
Simon thank you madam chair um the bill
as it's written doesn't appear to me to
have spiking protection in it does it
because when I'm looking at this in
comparison with some of the other bills
that are being brought forward for
example if we were to pass 1647 and 1653
1653 is going to have a pretty
substantial impact potentially on the
calculations of 1647 if I'm reading that
correctly because you're dealing with
actually changing the base pay of an
employee but where as there are those
complicated calculations in the
retirement system for most employees
this doesn't seem to have any of those
safeguards in it so the safeguards are
already in law this doesn't remove any
of the safeguards that are that are in
the statute now so it's not
necessary to have it in this particular
bill because they already
exist follow up follow up that's not
what the language says though it I mean
it would it's already in statute and
this bill is not changing it this bill
doesn't change would be in the
bill right I mean and maybe I'm just
misunderstanding forgive me if I am but
because the wording is overtime pay
included as base pay
correct would that not create then if
it's not replacing it wouldn't it create
a conflict in the language of Statute
because that's not what we do we don't
include all overtime pay as base pay we
have so what this would do is it makes
it stores
that calculation back down into how base
pay is calculated which is a fiveyear
average right yeah no I understand that
component of
it all right I'll I'll think about it a
little bit more okay are there any other
questions okay thank you very much for
your testimony you're welcome Mr
Carlin
if it's not changed it doesn't
necessarily need
to but notes to look at in
subit thanks again Madam chair again for
the record Marty Carlin representing
representing New Hampshire retirement
system uh we do not have a position on
this bill um the first bill we heard
today you know if we were you know if
this was a physics class would be sort
of how neutrons and protons and
electrons interact these next two bills
are more like particle you know physics
you know with you know all the Exotic
particles that go into those building
blocks there's a lot here to unpack so
I'm going to back up a little and just
kind of talk about comp over base and
Aral compensation because it will also
apply uh for the discussion on the
following bill this morning 16 uh 53 73
um so essentially prior to uh the
changes in 2011 uh
U legislate there were enumerated types
of pay in our statute base pay
overtime differentials Etc and
everything was if it was listed in the
statute as a compensation type that was
earnable compensation it was all
considered base pay uh by nhrs and the
pension was averaged out on that that
total those total amounts and that's how
the AFC was determined uh employers
reported it all in one line you know uh
for individual so we never had a
breakdown of what what was going into
the to being what was reported uh in
2011 the law changed for uh tier B
members and future hires uh so that
there was a new definition of of base
pay which is as defined by the employer
that's you know what's on your
contractor you know on your salary band
uh and compensation over base among the
things that could be included in
compensation over base and this is for
all members including Rec in future
hires is
overtime uh attendance bonuses or
stipend uh workers compensation
supplemental pay paid by the employer if
if they offered that longevity pay uh
and for tib only in group two extra or
special duty pay Cally known as detail
pay so those are the pieces that go into
comp over base so uh beginning with
January of
2012 uh employers were instructed to
begin reporting NH to
nhrs base pay compensation over base pay
and then also detail pay separately
because it applies differently for for
TR so they basically instead of having
one bottom line salary number reported
every month for an individual there
there were up to three components uh
that went into that bottom line so um
any calculations regarding compensation
Overbay or offsets things like that are
only based on salary earned after one
one of 12 if somebody everything was
base pay before then essentially
so and what what the law did in 2011 is
it assigned a a a cap um on compensation
over base pay and this this is where it
gets a little complicated basically it
says take
the find the five highest years salary
for that person and then look at in
those 5 years what percentage of that
compensation was compensation over base
pay versus base pay so um round number
you know if you had a $50,000 base and
25,000 and comp over base total of 75 so
a a third of your 75,000 was comp over
Bas so and HRS has to find that
percentage for those five years and then
you know put it over here and then we
have to look at the percentage of comp
over base pay in the other years worked
since
2012 find that percentage and then
whichever percentage is lower apply that
to the comp over base so you know and
that that that was slightly modified for
um group two tier b a couple years ago
and House Bill 1587 it was a little bit
of an improvement for them at the time
but only for that group all of group one
and uh tierc and group two were still
under this this formula and so what that
could do you know it it if you had had
again you you worked in a job where the
community had readily available over
time and you took it you picked up the
shifts you wanted to and your your comp
over base you know to in total not just
overtime was similar as a percentage
over the course of your years uh you
know there may be no haircut on the high
five or a little bit type of thing if
you only worked overtime in your high
five and didn't have any and only took a
base salary in those other years that's
a zero that that's not going to count so
that that's how it was capped I mean it
it's it's it's a complicated calculation
and it it makes it harder for a rank and
file member with a pencil in the back of
an envelope to sort of figure out their
pension you know they going to figure
out how many years they worked and they
know the multipliers but there's this
sort of unless they have every patri
stub they ever worked and you know saved
you know and they they you know
spreadsheet you know it you know there's
a little bit of uncertainty so this bill
uh would put overtime for tier B back
into base so it can't be Offset you know
it's not going to you know
be affected by the formula so that would
leave detail pay and those other sort of
lesser pay types as as comp over base
you know the expectation is that would
um you
know
um you know in incre increase a benefit
because the reduction you know the
possibility of a reduction was lesson
but again the change would affect
individual members individually there's
no blanket you can average out you know
a percentage once we have data but you
know it it it's depends on everybody's
individual pay history with this so
there's not a one one shop answer for it
so so that that's sort of the the short
version believe it or
not um and you know the the again it's
it's for for tier B only the previous
bill was tier B and C the fiscal impact
on this is is listed on the uh bill as a
representative employer contribution
increase and then uh contribution
amounts for 2026 again this would also
be an ongoing cost the rate increase
includes for this one both the unfunded
liability piece and future normal cost I
think the unfunded on this is a little
bit under 26.6 million so there's no no
appropriation attached to this this
would just be a change in law so all of
the the cost would F back into the
employer rates and U just just one thing
to to emphasize and pick up on what
representative Simon said earlier is all
any any set of retirement bills but
particularly these these three this
morning if you were looking to say well
how much if we pass them all how much
would it cost and if you look at the
fiscal notes and add them up that's not
going to get you the true answer because
they kind of compound on each other um
so that you know and we don't have have
and we wouldn't have an analysis unless
it was a combined bill um you know that
way because if your multiplier is larger
in your AFC is larger it's going to you
know going to be larger than if one of
the other was changed so you know there
there's a lot of moving Parts um you
know with this and you know so we would
have to have employers Again Begin
reporting over time as base for that
segment of members um going forward if
if the bill passed on the effective
date clct the answer questions thank you
Mr Carlin I believe that it helps
explain why the uh the commission mostly
decided to concentrate on the
multipliers so those were much more
understandable representative Simon
thank you madam chair and thank you Mr
Carlin um fiscal year 2025 it says
there's an indeterminable increase do
you have any idea why that particular
year is
indeterminable um is this on the f is
this on fisal Note yeah the first page
the fiscal note
okay oh inet terminal will do to
administrative cost related to
reprogramming so that's you know okay
you know they'll give us a price but you
know you know it'll give us a set of
hours because you probably probably be
you
know 50 to 150,000 I would you know
based on past history with some of the
stuff all right thank
youa thank you madam chair uh Mr Carlin
can you give us um an example of how for
example leaving your job for a
disability or
military U responsibilities would
affect this yeah yeah that that's
actually been been you know the issue
have we seen with individual people when
they've come in if you are even if
you're in that position where you know
you're working fairly consistent regular
amount of overtime and things like that
and it you know it and you were deployed
and you got service for those years or
you were on workers comp so you're only
getting a base pay you know when you're
doing that percentage that period of
time is a zero in there so so it it it
could lower it it down um considerably
depending on the period of you're you're
you're getting service but you're not
really active doing everything you were
able to before
so representative
leus thank you I mean this relates to to
uh an earlier question from
representative
Simon um if I'm understanding your
description of how it works now um that
is basically sort of an anti-s spiking
protection because it prevents you from
having during your high five years
deciding to work lots of overtime and
having that jack up your
pension um
but with this change in the bill it
seems that at least for the people who
um are affected who are hired before
July 1 2011 that it removes that anti-s
spiking U effect is that
correct y i I'll I'll defer to the def
definition of spiking because I I've
heard many um you know but but uh you
know I won't use that term but it it
reduces it increases the amount that
goes into base pay which there is no
Governor or cap on other than is you
know the maximum benefit limit or or
things like that so so it would likely
for people with you know who do overtime
over the course of their career increase
their
pensions okay thank you yes if it's
included in base pay however for the
period that it's in base pay it would
decrease the percentage of overtime
work because you'd have more in base pay
for the same amount of
overtime
not I'm not getting that um well if you
normally work 10% overtime Y and at this
and this bill passes and you work your
10% overtime you are showing zero above
base because it's in base so if that's
correct it could actually could it
reduce your pension no because it's the
lesser of the two percentages you know
the high high five versus the other
period so the if if if base wasn't if
you worked another five years after the
bill pass and your base pay was higher
your percentage of comp over base would
be lower so it would
hold
okay it's
complicated any other
questions all right and I'm hoping the
subcommittee is going to have a lovely
time dealing with this
one oh yes Mr
real
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh I will introduce myself
this time uh for the record Brian re I'm
the president of the professional
firefighters in New Hampshire uh we
represent approximately 2,000 active and
retired firefighters in the state um
I'll be uh a little bit brief on this
and and you won't have to hear from me
again today uh We've signed in support
on bills and and submitted written
testimony um but I do think it's fair to
address this
issue um this was uh another issue that
was discussed or a similar Bill like it
was discussed in the commission on uh
mandatory overtime and what that means
so in this profession and I know it was
uh mentioned a little earlier from
representative Pearson uh oftentimes
overtime is not an
option oftentimes overtime is
forced um we due to the Recruitment and
Retention issue which we all recognize
exists and we've all acknowledged exists
um we found a difficult time filling
vacancies in our departments which
creates a situation where cities in
towns must staff fire trucks we must
staff ambulances and we must staff
police cars it creates a situation where
if someone doesn't come to work whether
it be uh use of their vacation time
being sick or being disabled those
shifts still have to be filled the
trucks still need to respond to
emergencies and we still need to treat
the
public often times that means we're
being forced to hold over and forced to
stay at work this creates uh not only a
situation where a firefighter is unable
to return home creates a situation where
they're uh incre increasing their time
away from their family increasing their
time away from other obligations they
may have in life um in order to protect
the citizens of their
communities oftentimes this means
firefighters are expected to work 48
straight hours or
more creating health and safety issues
such as sleep
deprivation um behavioral health issues
substance abuse issues marital issues
and strain in the home
um our firefighters are being asked to
solve many of the world's problems and
as a thanks their overtime hours that uh
in many cases they're not given the
option to work are being extrapolated
and diluted down to work on a different
calculation um representative Pearson
said it best earlier uh that you can
work on a
Wednesday and your salary is worth one
amount but if you work on on a Thursday
it's worth uh it's worth something
different now what's interesting about
that is you're asking to be work or
you're being told to work more hours um
but you're not you're not getting the
increased benefit on the back end for
that um and I think that that is
something that we need to look at um and
and determine whether or not that's
fair
um while we're being expected to work
these additional hours um we should be
told that it's going to affect our
pension on the back end um I don't think
we're doing ourselves any any favors for
Recruitment and Retention so I would ask
for the committee's support on this bill
um and and another bill that you'll be
hearing on a later date uh similar to it
um but I would like to voice my support
for that thank you thank you other
questions yes represent gold thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question am I understanding correctly
that um what you're saying is that there
are times when workers are working
overtime and it's not to spike their
retirement but that the current
calculation becomes punitive against
positively impacting their retirement
benefits thank you for the question um I
wouldn't necessarily use the word
punitive because it is calculated um in
some manner it's just calculated in a uh
different manner than it used to be and
that number is diluted down um I I would
agree with the statement or or the part
of your question that says um often this
is not elective overtime that is
intended to spike one's pension uh again
there are mechanisms in place to uh
eliminate the spiking provision um
what's what's interesting to me is I
mentioned that the the Staffing models
that our fire departments
have in many cases there's not a lot of
leeway there the department has to be
staffed to a certain level as determined
by either the fire chief uh elected
officials in the cities or towns or
working agreements um so they have to
fill those seats whether or
not I'm electing to work that overtime
or someone else is being forced to work
that overtime the municipality is having
to pay the same percentage on that into
the retirement so
um it's being calculated in one way or
another on someone's pension um it would
be our position that it doesn't matter
whose pension that is whether it's
person a or person
B all right representative Schmidt and
then
ly thank you madam chair can you tell me
how
many uh departments or what the overall
shortfall is in terms of people that
that uh that would be on the job if they
could find him in the state of New
Hampshire that's a great question I it's
such a dynamic number I wouldn't be able
to give you we've tried to conduct
surveys in the past um what I can tell
you is that um the candidate Physical
Agility Test which is the entrance exam
to become a firefighter in the state we
used to see 500 to
550 uh candidates coming in to take that
test to be a fighter in the state and
that was uh around 2010 2011's numbers
um I think just recently the the most
recent year showed 191
candidates thank you repres
Manti thank you madam chair I have a
fundamental question what is the
definition of
overtime currently overtime means if I'm
hired for 40 hours uh a week job and if
my particular week if I work 50 hours
whether it was mandatory or elective
that would be considered as overtime
correct or number of shifts per month
and whatever the extra shift correct
thank you for your question uh I do
believe that this is um an flsa question
and it in many cases it's determined by
if you're in a union it's a collective
bargaining agreement um for instance
many departments are averaged over uh an
eight-week cycle and a 42h hour work
week um but I believe by
flsa um that that number of hours could
increase but whatever that number is
determined to be whether it's 42 hours
or 56 hours anything above and beyond
that would be time and a half would be
over time if I say is
the uh Fair Labor uh Fair labor
standards act thank
you representative blackis thank you so
I I think I understand you know the
concerns you've expressed but um could
you comment on the fact that this as I
read it this bill would only um help
with that situation for members who are
hired before July 1 2011 and are still
employed is that yes I believe that's
the way that I didn't write the bill but
that's the way it's written but I would
be supportive um of that language or um
better yet if we wanted to expand that
for everyone this was a benefit prior to
2011 for these folks which is why this
is relevant now okay thank you other
questions all right thank you very much
Mr Arthur
bodri
Madam chairman members of the committee
thank you again my name is ala bodri I
represent the New Hampshire State
permanent firefighters retirement
Association I also am a retired captain
of the Manchester fire department and I
sat on the Board of Trustees uh for 13
years uh this bill as I stated in prior
testimony for
1647 um this bill just wants to
recapture benefits that were taken away
from members that were hired uh before
2011 that's that's what this does they
want to restore benefits that were taken
away from them which was historical um
as representative um Pearson mentioned
uh that was the first time that benefits
were ever taken away from a member
normally uh it's either in to enhance a
benefit or if you're going to change the
benefit it's for new hires not existing
people that were hired so this is just
another
um bill and there's going to be probably
several others
until 436 comes to fruition uh that was
in 436 but this is again a piece of
legislation just to bring back benefits
that were taken away from members that
were already enrolled in the system and
to go back to
overtime uh departments Don't Make Up
Overtime just to enhance somebody's
pension it's to keep their Department
OCC uh working uh as as representative
over Brian mentioned um his Department
in Nashville um they have so many men
per shift or women uh members per shift
and they have to they have to work that
in Manchester when I was on the uh on
the department um as a committee I mean
representative um Pearson mentioned we
have a list of of our department and it
would go by um by the one who has you go
a rotating motion so you know same
person is not going to be getting
overtime every single time it it comes
up um and in Manchester it's really not
mandatory at least it wasn't when I was
on the job uh that if they couldn't find
somebody uh they would close a station
down so you're now you're getting less
protection in the city because they
would have to close either a engine
company down or a ladder company down
and take that Manpower and and disperse
it uh to to fill in the shifts that were
were vacant um and also the uh recently
uh in Manchester so we used to get paid
time and a half and they hired a bunch
of Subs that would come in um and
actually take over shifts because they
felt it was cheaper than paying time and
a half so they had floaters that would
come in they had so many captains so
many lieutenants so many uh firefighters
and when somebody called in sick this
floater would take their position well
when the department went to straight pay
those those positions were pretty much
absorbed and I don't believe they have
floaters anymore cuz it's actually
cheaper now to pay an individual to work
overtime at straight pay than it is to
hire somebody and pay all the extra
benefits so it actually benefits uh the
Departments to have them work in the
overtime at straight pay um so with that
I will answer any questions thank you
are there any
questions thank you hold done is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
1653 all right seeing none I will close
the hearing and open the hearing on
1673 and call Representative Pratt back
up same deal and representative
Pearson
hello thank you for listening to our
testimony uh 16 let's see 1673 is going
to be basically what we've talked about
already one of the compensations that we
had
lost I plans on doing that this is I'm
Kevin Pratt representative Kevin Pratt
from Raymond New Hampshire retired fire
chief firefighter for 42 years uh if I a
chieve for 29 um I was working at the
time that uh in 2011 when they made
changes to full-time employees uh taking
away over seven benefits that really
drastically reduced their end
retirement and one of the reasons I ran
for State Rep was to try to improve that
situation so if you read six uh 1673
you'll see that it is uh a very small
adjustment instead of uh calculating
your base pay over your whole career
it's going to be a it's going to make it
down to seven years you can imagine if
you're bringing into a formula your
first year employment um and you've
worked 30 years your first year of
employment is a lot different than your
last year of employment so when you
throw in a whole life time of our hourly
yearly wages it really would reduce the
amount of money that you would retire at
at the end and that change was a drastic
change that was made in
2011 so that is one of the changes we're
bringing back that was was in the
original bill that we were talking about
earlier so I add to that sure so this
this is just like um 1653
1673 th both of these are Provisions
that were in House Bill
436 now in this particular case um we
got two things going on here the first
first one is there is a reference typo
in line one thank you ol we'll we'll
address it when it when that comes it's
a I mean it could be handled in enrolled
bills technically but it's there is a if
you could explain it please sure uh
instead of RSA 100a Roman numeral 13
It's supposed to have a little bitty V
in between the X and the first
I that makes it 10 D3 10 V b i i i so
instead of 13 it's actually
18 yeah
ah thank you that will make a difference
I'm sure absolutely so so to so what
this does is this is this is a comp over
base thing right so the prior Bill
addressed
overtime the rest of that is your comp
over base so that involves details and a
lot of the other ancillary stuff that
that under the law was changed it was
the that's actually the first
retroactive thing that was ever done it
was done in 2009 and really kind of flew
under the radar when that went from a
three-year average to a seven-year
average so this doesn't restore it back
to the original Three but it puts it at
a Level Playing Field with everybody
else who's at it who's at seven right
now and that it just mirrors that
language that's all it does so
um one of the things that I've asked Mr
Carlin because he and I speak a lot is
what what happened prior to
2012 right because this this
change goes back to everyone so if you
were hired in
1984 that changed for you as well we
changed that this for vested people
people in
2009 and like I said it very much flew
under the radar
so how do you how do you deal with a a
formula to which you have no
data because we didn't collect it as as
Marty said prior to 2012 the reporting
didn't didn't go that way they just
handed you a number so they can't
calculate it prior to
2012 it just doesn't exist so if you do
a 30-year career and you retire
tomorrow when they do your career
average it's really just since
2012 but for those moving
forward that's not the
case this legislation does not carve
out anybody this puts the entire run
back to I'm sorry incorrect this does
carve out the group my apologies this
one does the same thing as the other one
did it's the folks that were retroactive
L changed in
2011 so your group your tier I know
we're using tiers that are not in
statute but we'll call those the tier B
folks
um and that's that's what that does it
mirrors the language of tier
a thank you are there any questions
representative Schmidt and AV
py thank you madam chair you did say
that the all these bills are going a
subcommittee right absolutely we as for
Mr Carlin pointed out you can't consider
one without the other because the
effects are not linear
right I I I understand what's happening
here I just don't know how to fix it
either represent man
py thank you Madame chair I I'm new to
this uh committee so my question is when
the changes happened in 2011
nobody was
grandfathered that and there was
no compensation for people who have
already served are at the cusp of
getting a bet so you're trying to fix
but this is not retroactive this is only
going forward correct no this this would
this would go back to 2012 when when the
retirement system required a a
separation or categorization of of your
overall
salary it can't go beyond 2012 because
there's no data it just doesn't exist
they re representative maputi the people
who were vested that has had more than
10 years of service at the moment of
determination were not affected by the
change the people what the people who
were affected it will go into the
calculation of their retirement which is
not yet final so it's not exactly
retroactive but it does include the
benefit of the year's
work just to follow up to clarify Madam
chair so if in that case if they're
still continuing to work here they will
get the benefit if they have already
moved on right too B correct you don't
have it once the person retires their
their pension is fixed and not changed
unless the legislature decides to Grant
a cost of living increase thank you yep
that is true okay other other
questions all right just one more
statement before I leave I I hear um the
talk of
spiking you know overtime is figured for
most people that work over 40 hours
firemen can quite often be 52 hours
before the overtime even kicks in so
that's a self-limiting factor right
there if you're working 52 hours are not
getting overtime 12 hours of that is
straight pay so that's kind of a
self-limiting factor right there in the
fact that you're not really spiking and
if you're only doing it for a few years
figur over seven years that's um really
a pretty much leveling field right there
it really levels it out and um the other
thing is we talk about new benefits
these are all these builds I'm looking
forward are not new benefits these are
benefits that were lost for people that
are already working here for 10 years so
we're just looking to try to get back
what was lost not looking for new
benefits new money for people we're not
looking for new benefits or new money
thank you thank you yeah other
questions all right thank you very much
Mr
Carlin Madam chair again Marty Carlin
representing nhrs the retirement system
doesn't have a position on this bill um
as in my prior testimony it the similar
to the last hearing on 1653 in the sense
that um you know this
bill does something different to the
comp over base formula it shortens it
for group two tier B so instead of a
look back as that percentage of comp
over base from point of retirement back
to one one of 12 it's going to look at
their last seven years from their
effective date of retirement if if the
high five for that person was in those
last seven years it's a much more
probably the percentages are going to be
very similar um type of thing so so
that's that's basically how this bill
would work
um and um yeah that's be glad to answer
any
questions are there any
questions uh representative leas thank
you so um I guess currently it's it's
the high five that the pension is based
on and you're looking at the overtime
averaging um with this
change I guess it says the last seven so
if somebody were if their high five were
well before the end of their career for
some reason which probably is unlikely
but would it actually potentially reduce
uh their
pension you know it pro quite possibly I
mean you know because it's it's the
lesser of the percentage in the high
five and the other five so yeah it could
have an an adverse effect on on somebody
depending on their circumstances and a
example of that may be somebody who was
um you know had the opportunity to you
know do overtime and detail pay 10 years
earlier went into Command Staff they
were on a salary didn't get that anymore
and they made more in their old job you
know um you they made more in the
cruiser than behind the desk you know
type of thing that you know so it's
possible okay thank you
any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Mr car
thank you is there anybody else who
wishes to testify on hb1
1673 uh seeing none I will close the
hearing on hp1 1673 and we will recess
for lunch uh we'll see everybody back
here at 1:15 p.m. thank
you
Pur
all good afternoon everyone welcome
back opening the public hearing on House
Bill
1299 and I call Representative
tro thank you madam chair and members of
the Edna committee I'm representative
District uh correction 8 out of Belmont
tilted and
sington today I come before you with
House Bill
12299 FN so basically I was asked to
bring this forward um the reason for
this bill is currently um fire
instructors at the Academy are in the
group two
retirement
whereas instructors at community
colleges that are teaching the same um
type of um education as the um fire
academy and not they're actually group
one so basically um my understanding
there's only uh one or two that are
affected by um this so it wouldn't be a
huge impact to the retirement or um
would affect the group to retirement so
at this point I'm going to have the
person that asked me to bring this um
forward to speak more on this bill but I
do ask this committee to please take a
close look at this and hopefully we can
pass this thank
you thank you um I'd like to have Mr
Carlin exp do as we did in all the other
bills and have Mr Carlin explain explain
the financial impact first if
that's that's fine thank you okay Mr
Carlin
good afternoon um Marty Carlin
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system um nhrs doesn't have a
position on this bill um from our
understanding and reading the fiscal
note from Community College it currently
affects one member um and if you know
basically what happens is you know there
obviously the two member groups and
there different defs in the statute to
qualify for uh you know teacher police
and fire you know it's a fairly long
list of definitions but typically Group
Two Fire the primary definition is
permanent full-time firefighter with or
others with regular exposure to the
hazards of of firefighting um there are
exceptions um that's the statute that's
being amended um A3 section 3C there are
a couple of positions in there that have
been carved out over time time to stay
in group two if you're bringing someone
into the position who had prior service
in group two of more than uh 10 years so
um you know that's sort of the mechanics
of it if it's not changing the
definition of eligibility for a
firefighter but it's adding this
particular job position into the
exceptions where somebody who's already
been in group two can stay in group two
in the position in terms of the cost uh
basically the difference is the um
employer rate well you know the ex the
member rate for group Two Fire is 11.8%
and group one is 7% but the the employer
contribution rate is um significantly
larger for the employer the group one
rate for employers is
13.5 13.85 and the fire rate is
30.354701 now the reason why I think
some of the existing car outs have been
in there is there are certain benefits
available only to group two members who
retire as group two members primarily a
50% automatic spousal allowance if they
pass away that 50% of the pension goes
to the spouse with no reduction there
may be medical subsidy eligib issues as
well so that that's sort of the draw for
wanting to stay in group two uh for some
reason so that's um that's pretty much
it in a
nutshell
okay thank you uh I have a question I'm
looking at the fiscal note and that
seems to imply that you're going to
raise the rate for every employee in the
community
system um if it was written that way
it's not intended it would be on the
individual who the affected individuals
or individual who went St who what is in
group one now and would go to group two
this this is similar there was a
dispatcher Bill a couple years ago that
was the same idea okay so it's only on
the yeah only on the person thank you
that I appreciate that any other
questions
BR thank you Madame chair on page I mean
on line8 it says any fire instructor
fire educator for the community college
system what's the difference between a
fire instructor and a fire and educator
um I if if please correct me if I'm
wrong anyone behind me I I think fire
that speaks to fire academy
instructors the community college system
isn't you know it's it's you know the
the you know the fire fire academy you
know under safety okay thank you we'll
we'll there are some people that will be
able to
explain okay any other questions from Mr
Carlin representative
O'Brien um thank you madam chair uh Mr
Carin did we past leg lures try to fix
something like this like in other words
in the example fire chiefs were getting
secretaries to join the group two type
of pension
system and
um then we de Bild uh the law was
changed that they had to complete
firefighter one and firefighter 2
training in order to qualify and with
these people that they are talking about
if you're prepared to answer that
could they meet the standards of
firefighter one firefighter 2 couldn't I
that's a question outside of my scope
but to to your your your initial
question my understanding is back 30 40
50 years ago there were some positions
because they were working for a police
or fire department you know as an admin
you know they were in group two and that
that was tightened up over the
years it's 80s early 90s time frame some
of those type of position you know there
were additional definitions put in for
you know tightening up the eligibility
but it's it's been the way it's been
since I've been around okay
representative O'Brien if you look at
lines 9 10 and 11 which are existing law
it says that that the person has to have
as a job requirement satisfy the
entrance and certification
requirements that's which is I think
what you're talking about yeah five five
one and two thank you madam
chair else represent laus uh thank you
so I'm just trying to understand if
somebody has worked as let's say fires
their group
two and you know they're vested or maybe
even eligible for retirement and then
they take a group one job you're saying
they actually lose some portion of what
would have been their group two benefits
yeah yeah they they would in in cases
like that where somebody goes either
from group one to group two or group two
to group group one they they end up
retiring with what we call a split
benefit and their service in one group
is calculated under the formulas for
that group and their service in the
other group is calculated you know yeah
follow the the situation is that if you
retire as group two you get a couple of
specific additional benefits that you
wouldn't if you had a split pension and
also if you do have a split pension your
Social Security if any will will be
severely impacted by your group two
pension H because the federal rule in
the C is that because you didn't have
contributions during those years it's
worse than that worse than that all
right thank
you yeah okay anyone else all right
thank you Mr Carlin thank you
representative
Pearson thank you madam chair for the
record representative C Pearson
Rockingham District 13 which encompasses
the town of dairy I have 27 years in a
fire service I currently work as a
lieutenant for the city of Manchester
fire so I'm going to touch on a question
or two that I've already heard and then
and then we'll go from there as a
general practice I I'm not in favor of
this bill I I I see some some problems
with this uh but to answer that first
question about um the group two in their
status looking at the language of this
bill any permanent firefighter who has
been a group two member in order to be a
group two member there are minimum
requirements that they would have had to
have met so they would they would meet
that in in that sense um as far as what
the difference between a fire instructor
and a fire educator for the community
college system the community college
system does not have a fire training
grounds so when they light things on
fire they have have to do it at the fire
academy the folks that handle that at
the fire academy are fire academy folks
because they're using their facility and
the employees at the fire academy deal
with that so the the fire educator in
the community college system is pretty
much in the in a classroom environment
which to me
separates what they do versus what a
fire instructor does in the sense that
the folks at the fire Academy that are
instructing with things that are on fire
are in a dangerous
environment teaching a codes class at
the community college system's not quite
the same they're they're doing it in a
classroom setting so there's a
distinction there between the two of
those one of the interesting things
about this bill on line 11 talks
about that you would have to meet the
job requirements for entrance and
certification requirements for the
physical conditioning that current exam
is the cpad exam and what what this
would say for those classroom Educators
they would have to take the
cpat exam and pass it in order to meet
this
requirement we're talking about the
concept of bringing folks in that have a
lot of years of
experience that is going to be a hurdle
for a lot of them right I'm 47 okay if I
had to if unannounced I had to take that
cpad exam right now I'd probably make it
but I would probably be admitted to the
hospital shortly therea so halfway
through you know so again they would
obviously know this ahead of time but
this is this is now a requirement that
is being put forward for a classroom
educator in essence here by adding them
to
this the other situation that I I
question in this is is an equity thing
is as far as is this going to require
all of the fire Educators in the
community college system is it going to
become optional what about the ones that
have never served in the fire service
that have been in the academic setting
less than 10 years if I've got two
people teaching the same class on
different days one of them's in group
two one of them's in group one they're
doing the same thing that that causes a
little bit of confusion I think in my
mind
for keeping consistent across the board
so I
can I I wasn't approach with this I I
really don't know the precipice of why
this this was I and I apologize to
representative charer I didn't even he
and I haven't even really talked about
this as to as to where this was coming
from but there's just some logistical
things here that I think are are not
going to make this work
overall thank you are there questions
representative
O'Brien thank you um and and I know you
may not be an expert in this but are
there instructors at the Academy that
aren't
Associated you know with a full-time
department they working within the
volunteer oh yeah uh type of environment
so they don't meet the annual standards
like I think you guys in Manchester I
know we in Nash had to meet annual
certifications that may not be true in
all departments across the state correct
sure I mean one of the things that you
you know if you live in the southern
part of the state you you get a little
disillusion to how everybody north of
conquered survives the volunteer fire
service is over 80% of the fire service
in the state of New
Hampshire and there's a lot of
differences um
between the career folks mostly in the
southern part of the city and in the
volunteer fire
service one of the things that this
shuts
off
because you would had to have been a
member of group
two is that if you came from the
volunteer fire service this does not
apply to
you because you're never in group two so
you've if this is not going to be a
benefit for anybody that came from that
part of this profession so that again as
an equity thing you could have a fell
that's got 20 years as a in the fire
service in New Hampshire but came from
the volunteer ranks teaching alongside
someone with 10 years who came from a
municipality they're teaching the same
thing but this guy is not eligible for
this because he was a volunteer and this
guy is
so and in the community college setting
I I just don't see how that works I just
don't see
it thank you representative
Simon thank you madam chair thank you
representative Pearson um for your
testimony uh from your perspective is it
beneficial to try to amend this at all
to address some of the concerns that
you're talking about or are you just
talking about from your perspective on
principle so what keeping in mind that
this entire paragraph is only being
modified in one spot very very
small to make a modification to try to
work around that is is would be a
fundamental change of the entire
section I don't think that's a good idea
I I think that that you're you're going
to have to do a deeper dive into a whole
lot of other things here and taking that
apart in a in a setting right now that
as far as I know is working pretty well
I I just don't think it's
necessary thank you other questions
thank you very
much Mr
nurri
and get closer there we go good
afternoon Madam chair and rest of the
committee uh I appreciate your time this
afternoon my name is Nick mccu and I'm
that guy that we've been referring to um
what I would like to explain is I'm here
on my own I am a resident of Meredith um
I am not here on behalf of my employer
what I did want to bring up out is and
try to answer some of the questions that
have come up is my current role is
actually department chair of the fire
science program at Lakes Region
Community College and within that role
um as you have seen we are acutely aware
that there is a crisis within Emergency
Services you yourselves as a legislator
legislators within the state have dealt
with this issue in trying to shore up
the Emergency Services System you've
taken many positive steps including the
recent passage of House Bill 2 with some
Senator waters's um wording that created
actually a career development program
and funded that program not only at the
pity college system excuse me but also
at the New Hampshire fire academy to try
to once again Shore up that system I
believe that program will make a
significant
difference as been mentioned Lakes
Region Community College is the only
fire science program within the state
and we work very collaboratively with
the fire academy in the past two years
we've actually doubled our program we
now have approximately 40 incoming first
year students and that's been for the
past couple of years and I really hope
that that continues especially with the
new program in addition during our last
search which is why this conversation uh
came up with representative tradier is
that we had approximately I believe
seven instate very well-qualified
candidates one of them being a a not a
retiring but a fire chief that was
looking at retiring that thought he
would be able to bring his knowledge to
the community college system and not
retire all of those instate individuals
withdrew their applications when they
found out that they would have to make a
group change from group two to group one
that meant as you've heard before a loss
in benefits not all of them but enough
to make a difference so we lost those
instate candidates this bill is an
attempt to actually address that
shortcoming when representative Traer
and I discussed what some of the options
were creating additional group two
positions reclassifying the two
positions that were there did not seem
appropriate it seemed to be kind of a
heavy-handed approach to deal with our
issue and with our challenge so what we
did do is some research and we found the
RSA that is already on the books that
provides a very narrow exception to the
group two standard and as has been
mentioned by several Representatives
this isn't a cart blanch entrance into
group two there are some very high bars
to
meet some of those bars include being a
fire 2 certified person within the state
it also includes having 10 years at
least experience within our state and
there are some other additional um
requirements as you've already heard um
the cpat and passing the cpat is one of
them I don't believe it would be redoing
the cpad if you've taken it once to be a
group two member you have to take the
cpad so that my assumption would be
already be done and I completely agree I
would not want to be taking that cpad
again at my age that would not go well I
would be definitely in the hospital just
like the
representative so like I said in our
discussions we found RSA 100a 3
subsection C which allowed a very narrow
exception and that's what you see uh in
front of you it generally states that
any permanent fireman who has 10 years
of experience any fire instructor
supervisor or other technical specialist
who has firefighting education as a job
function can remain in the system we
Tred to touch that law as little as
possible because I do agree
representative Simon that if we do try
to do too much then we really open up a
very large can so representative try and
I tried to do this a little bit more
surgically as opposed to broadly so this
bill really seeks to clarify and make
clear that the instructors and the
Educators not only at the Academy but at
the community college that are teaching
the same topics while there is a little
bit more Hands-On at the fire academy I
do agree we still do have fire props at
our AC at at the community college
system including something called a
dollhouse uh also some um alcohol props
that we can use and actually burn within
our classroom and a fire sprinkler prop
so we do have some of those actually at
the community college system but what I
do want to emphasize is that many of the
topics that you're going to learn in
firefighter 1 the community college
system our job is to make your knowledge
deeper so take fire behavior and
combustion you may take that at the fire
academy I can teach that class in an
entire semester so the academy will give
you your foundation I'm going to give
you the education behind it not just the
technical aspects of how to deal with
fires so in closing I want to reiterate
that this bill does not create any group
two positions it does not reclassify any
group two positions it clarifies a
current RSA that's already on the books
that requires that 10 years of
experience meeting the current
firefighter standards within the state
is a requirement to actually have this
um to have this benefit or to have this
change to remain in group
two um without this change I'm very
fearful that we are going to encounter
another issue like we did a couple of
years ago and there are only two fire
instructors by the way at the academy
one of the gentlemen that we were able
to hire was a wonderful find but he was
relocating from North Carolina so
luckily we were able to pick up Dustin
which we're very grateful for um and I
do understand that that makes one person
potentially have been group two and one
person not but I think within the fire
service we understand that if you're
doing a different role even if you're
teaching the same topics you may get
different benefits whether you're a fire
officer or whether you're a firefighter
you may get different benefits even
working for the the same employer so
thank you very much for your time I I
very much appreciate it and the
opportunity to come and speak and I'm
happy to try to answer questions if you
have any I oh yes representative leus
and then sh it okay there was a
statement or concern uh raised by a
previous speaker that if we pass this um
trying to see if I get this right
that you would no longer be able to hire
somebody who was not a uh
a member of group two in New Hampshire
prior to this do you read that this that
way or I do not we were able to hire any
individual the benefit of this is that
if we had someone with 10 years plus
experience they would be able to go from
their fire department to teaching the
next generation of firefighters without
a loss in benefits and and like I had
mentioned we lost approximately seven
very well qualified instate candidates
because they did not want to lose their
benefits so we would be able to hire
anybody even outside group two okay
thank you representative Shu thank you
madam chair um of those seven candidates
that you say you lost do you can you
tell us do you know why they wanted to
work for you but not for the fire
academy um I can't answer that directly
there is a different role within what
I'm doing and what the fire academy is
doing as we've discussed it's a lot more
physical there I don't know um the exact
answer answer to that coming into
Academia could have been their lifelong
dream I don't
know followup thank you um also I'm
curious um from the students
perspective uh would a person who
graduates from your community college
class get the same
certification as someone who goes
through the fire academy excellent
question thank you we actually have two
tracks at the community college system
we have a certificate one-ear track and
we have an Associates two-year track
both of those require our students to go
to the fire academy and get their
certification as a condition of actual
graduation thank you repres manuti
oh thank you madam chair so to follow up
to that question so your program is a
feeder program to the fire academy
yes and uh they have to in order to
become a certified sorry followup Madam
it's no go on yes uh so with the uh fire
acade the students coming out of
community college system and going to
the fire academy that's a must for them
to get into fire uh Department in New
Hampshire yes the certification is
what's required and that like I
mentioned we work very closely with the
academy and it's a condition of our
graduation I can't speak to what the
employers are using for their minimum
standards for um for hiring we've been
put into some very um interesting times
where it used to be a firefighter 2 and
a paramedic is what they wanted and they
wouldn't take anything else I think many
departments have been rethinking that um
to get the right person in the
door thank
you yes one
more sorry madam um thank you um so how
if a volunteer
firefighter they have to go through the
certification
too um it depends on their department
whether they require firefighter one and
two to be employed or not but we have
not only individuals that are looking
for a full-time job we have graduated
individuals that are just looking to be
their volunteer and serve in their own
Community but they may have a profession
already um but they wanted the
additional knowledge um and
certifications to be an on call
firefighter as opposed to
full-time B Smith you had a
question Madam chair um I have a
question uh probably coming from the
wrong segment of society here when
you're teaching in an an institution
like the community college system don't
you have to be certified as a teacher no
not within the commity college system no
you need to have a a background and an
expertise within the particular field
there are some positions like mine
require master's degree um specifically
the topic might be a little bit wider
but it's those job requirements that we
need to actually fulfill okay because I
was going to say if they have to be
certified as a teacher they would be in
group one not in group we are not okay
thank
you thank you madam chair so if you
wanted to to be a
firefighter you could go directly to the
fire academy correct correct follow up
follow so what is the benefit of going
to the Community College first and then
going to the fire academy actually they
happen at the same time so any of the
individuals that come into our
Associates or certificate program they
take firefighter one and two either in
their first semester or their second
semester if the class is
full
so this is more background more detail
on things that the academy doesn't have
time to cover is what I got the
impression you were saying yes if I
misunderstood the question I apologize
it it's not um one or the other it's
actually in parallel and chair Maguire
hit it right on the head is that I have
time to go into many of the topics
building construction over an entire
semester where there may be only be a
couple of class days at the Academy
count okay representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here taking my
question I just want if you could
address the concern a little more
because it comes to my concern as well
as you can have two
instructors one who was a volunteer on a
volunteer
department not in group two another
instructor in group
two you truly believe that there
wouldn't be a conflict between those two
as one getting a better benefit than the
other doing the same job because I don't
see that I see you'll be back here in
two years if you have two people in that
saying they need the same benefit
because it's not
working I truly believe that that
wouldn't be a conflict it should be
something that's discussed initially at
the outset and I'll use uh Dustin as a
as an example Dustin has a new a North
Carolina where Dustin came from a
retirement the expectation that they
should be in the same system and earn
the same benefits I think it was
discussed that part of this uh benefit
process is putting yourself in that
Harm's Way using this RSA means you've
already done that for a minimum of 10
years if you're first coming to our
state I think that expectation probably
does not track um appropriately and
having two individuals with the with
different actual benefits is not going
to be a challenge under that kind of an
umbrella
follow
so you think someone who
works and is a member of group two and
does 10
years ought to have the ability to be
sitting in a classroom for the next 20
years while someone in the fire service
does 30 years In Harm's Way and collect
the same
benefit I think that's what's on the
books right now as far as the laog goes
and it allows an individual to actually
have this
benefit I can't speak more to that if an
individual wanted to stay In Harm's Way
for 30 years and have the same benefit
we looked at the law that was already
there and tried to make a a small change
to that I completely understand your
question and don't want to set up any
kind of disparity but at the same time
like I said we took a look at the RSA
that was there and seemed to say did
this make sense and getting the
individual that we want to teach our
next
Generation that's the indiv idual with a
10 years plus
experience representative
Simon thank you madam chair the last
question just got me thinking on a
different train so um yes if I if I'm
reading you correctly uh the distinction
is that they've given 10 years of
service potentially In Harm's Way as
differentiating them from a candidate
that hasn't done that and therefore
would be in a different system um what
is the what's the average a age of an
instructor that comes to the Institute
to
teach oh um good
question if there's only one or two it's
a average is a very
uh yes there's only two of us and Dustin
and I replaced individuals that were
there for 32 years so I don't know that
I can answer that
appropriately follow up follow up yeah
the the only reason why I'm asking the
question is because uh even to become
invested in the system requires 10 years
at this point and arguably if somebody
wasn't going to be there for 10 years
this might not be the best path for them
to take anyway um so was just thinking
about it from that angle and then
representative goalie threw a curveball
at me and brought it at something else
into my mind so but I just want some
clarification on that so thank you no
problem thank you for the question all
right is everyone sufficiently confused
all right other
questions okay yes representa f
thank you madam chair going back to the
question why someone would want to do
the one or the two the two
years they're getting college credits
for that is that is that not correct
that is correct so that could lead to a
bachelor some at some time in the future
is that correct that is correct thank
you thank you madam chair anyone
representative gold and just uh thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question and just to follow up on
what representative Fitzpatrick asked is
the associate um portion you listed you
have two different tracks is your
associate track in fact an associate
degree it is it is a conferred
associates degree in as thank you y okay
else thank you very much thank you for
your time Miss
Reed
hello Madam chairman and Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Shannon Reed and I'm here on behalf of
the community college system of New
Hampshire um the community college
system respectfully and regretfully
opposes uh House Bill
1299 it would create inequities among
faculty positions within the community
college system um and would create
positions in group two that we feel do
not do not meet the historical criteria
for such classification I'd like to
provide a little bit of background um
about the relationship between the
community college system and uh
nhrs for much of the Community College
systems history we were part of the
state of New Hampshire part of its
administrative structure like the
Department of Transportation or the
Department of Education ccsnh employees
were state employees and were at the
time classified as group one within
nhrs legislation in
2007 moved the community college system
out outside of State Administration and
vested governance Authority in a Board
of
Trustees however the community college
system remained an employer within nhrs
and employees continue to be classified
as group one employees and in my written
testimony I will um provide you with the
relevant statutory citations for for
that
relationship House Bill 1299 would
extend group two status to fire
instructors within New Hampshire's
community college system we have the
only the state's only only associate
degree and certificate programs in fire
science offered at Lakes Region
Community College in lonia it is an
exceptional and valuable program within
the state of New Hampshire and for every
municipality that depends on First
Responders and we are extremely proud of
it while we understand the challenges
associated with uh recruiting
instructors as as were discussed by the
previous speaker we don't support
legislation that treats one type of
faculty member differently than the
others across ccsnh these are instructor
positions they're not positions where
the individual can be called into
Service as a first responder which is
the basis for group two
classification while the fiscal impact
is modest we're also concerned that this
legislation could open the door to other
faculty groups seeking similar
reclassifications based on recruitment
objectives thank you and I would be
happy to take any
questions thank you are there
questions representative
Manti thank you madam chair so when you
talk about about uh creating uh opening
the door for other uh fields in uh
Community College systems are you
thinking in terms of Criminal Justice
courses coursework
or any other which are first responder
thing I'm thinking specifically in terms
of our uh criminal justice programs
yes thank you Simon thank you madam
chair thank you for testifying today um
I just wanted to ask a a clarifying
question I suppose on uh your comment
that you didn't want to create different
benefits for different people with in
the system itself um from your
perspective if we weren't to pass a bill
like this would that not also happen um
because somebody who's coming with a
group to say somebody worked 15 years
for the fire service they're already
vested as a group two employee and
they're coming with their group two
retirement benefits that group two
benefit that they've achieved is going
to be affected in a different way by
going to group one that a group one
person doesn't have to deal with is that
correct I think I would defer to Mr
Carlin to answer that question M Mr
Carlin if you move within groups and it
goes both ways you you
are really short answer but you know if
you have service in both groups over the
course of your career you're going to
retire from the group your last position
and there are some differences and and
um supplemental besides the pension
formulas there some ancillary benefits
for group two that if you retired in
group one you wouldn't receive so that's
that's the
difference um my major concern is with
the interaction with Social Security um
because the social security benefit will
affect the group two benefit will it not
if they if they take on another 20 years
of social security benefit how will that
impact their group two benefit they
previously affect their group to benefit
it will affect their social security
right so that either either way that's
what I'm saying it they're going to lose
some benefit aren't they yeah well
there's the the the nhrs benefits is all
I can speak to is what what they would
lose there there is groups who isn't
doesn't contribute to Social Security in
New Hampshire right um and there is
something under the social secur law
called the windfall elimination weap uh
provision where by the years outside of
Social Security if you worked enough
quarters to get Social Security that
Social Security amount is going to be
offset by the the period outside the
system I mean if you work 28 years and
you could you know it's it's a sliding
scale and it's very complicated so that
that affects all group two members now
as as a as a as a thing but your
question did raise another point and
this is that's put it back to you
because you probably but um if the
position becomes group two although you
know this is a social security employer
would this be a group two position that
was also contributing to Social Security
that I don't know that but I as you
brought it up it's might happen an
interesting yeah okay thank you for your
answer and sorry for dragging you into
the middle of that one worri right any
more questions in the
weeds yes representative Brown uh thank
you madam chair could you just repeat
who you represent I missed that sure uh
my name is Shannon Reed and I'm here on
behalf of the community college system
of New Hampshire I'm director of
government
Affairs anyone else thank you very much
Mr
B thank you again Madam chairman uh
members of the committee for the record
my name is Arthur bodri I represent the
New Hampshire State permanent
firefighters retirement Association
again I'm a retired captain from the
Manchester fire department and I serve
13 years On The Board of Trustees for
the New Hampshire retirement
system uh we are in opposition of House
Bill
1299 um and the reasoning
is uh the reason why group two evolved
back in 1974 when we got the 20year bill
was because of um H the hazards of the
job and the life expectancy when I was
on the Retirement Board we actually used
a different mortality table for
firefighters because our life expectancy
was shorter than a normal population by
some 10 years and it has to do with the
stresses and the physical activity that
we have to go through uh when you have a
controlled environment teaching in a
classroom um you honestly you can have
almost any teacher in a state say that
they have um stressors in the classroom
so where does that stop uh back in the
90s they did a reclassification and they
took a lot of people out of group two
that they felt did not meet the criteria
of rigor and and um and Hazard we had
our dispatchers used to be in group two
our mechanics used to be in group two um
the mechanics they actually in
Manchester they go to fire scene and
they're you know they're working on
equipment and everything right there at
the fire scene um but they were taken
out of group to um and again it's
because of the job um when you look at
uh
um the the rate if if take for instance
a group one person Works 30 years they
would get 50% of their salary but they'
be eligible for full full-time Social
Security full Social Security where a
group two member the same 30 years under
the existing law uh depending I'm
talking about new hires after
2012 uh would get 60% but with no help
with no social security and then if you
if the with the change if somebody came
into the college system and they had 10
years of group two and then they did
another 20 years in group one and that's
why we have split benefits they would
get
53.4% on the as a pension and they would
also be eligible for Social Security so
um I think the way the law reads now is
we should leave it the way it is I I
don't we don't want to see group two
getting watered down anymore uh because
that's what happened back in the 70s and
80s people wanted to jump into group two
a lot of it was because of cost it was
cheaper to be in group two than it was
in group one um but uh as far as the
benefit structure I I would question
once you reach 65 years old if group two
is any better than group one uh when you
take consideration social security so
for those reasons um we oppose the bill
and we would hope that the committee um
itls it thank you and I'll take any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions
no thank you thank is thanks again is
there anybody else who wishes to testify
on House Bill
1299 okay seeing
none I will close the
hearing and open the hearing on House
Bill
1211 and call Representative
Pro
want that one too
okay good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee uh I'm Mark PR
representative Mark f um Hillboro 15 I'm
also uh a deputy chief in the town of
eeping and that is one of the main
reasons I put this bill in is because
departments especially in that I know of
in my area are having uh trouble getting
people to fill our
shifts
uh the newer
generation doesn't like to work
overtime uh at five minutes of six they
standing by the door ready to leave um
but
retirees will
work um so I asked for the hours
to uh be
increased so that we have the
opportunity to use the
retirees to help fill these
positions I know most of the departments
in our area work 12-hour
shifts so I put it in increments of 12
in the increase for a
year
and I know this probably won't be very
popular but some of the reasons
that um we're not getting candidates
knocking down our doors to come get
hired at our fire departments is because
of the changes that happened in our
retirement system a lot of them are are
headed to Massachusetts I know some of
them have even left early to head to
Mass
Massachusetts where we used to think
their retirement was horrible but it is
now better than ours so um we are in a
really tough position to recruit and
retain members so we're looking to some
of the uh retirees to come help us
out it does have a a
10-year uh sunset provision because I
don't want this to go forever and I'm
hoping that we can
over those 10 years make our retirement
system a little more attractive or
whatever to get more people to come back
to our state to fill these positions and
police Fire
EMS um and such and I'll take any
questions thank you very much are there
any
questions well I'm getting the any thank
you explained it very
well Mr
Carlin
thank you madam chair again Marty Carlin
representing nhrs uh nhrs doesn't have a
position on this bill I I signed up to
give a little bit of background on the
current working after retirement
landscape and answer any questions folks
might have uh the most recent changes to
the uh rules governing retirees working
part-time for participating employ EMP
lawyers and collecting a pension were
enacted in 2018 effective 1 of 19 uh
that set a limit for of 1352 hours per
calendar year for um any
retirees taking on you know
post-retirement employment after that
point uh there was a grandfathering
provision included in that statute that
any retire already working part-time for
a participating employer uh was allowed
to work
1664 hours in a calendar year uh and as
long as they stayed in that same
position with that same employer so
there there are some folks who were
still in that grandfathered status that
you know that number is closed pool as
of one one of 19 and will continue to
drop 1352 averages out to 26 hours a
week but it is not a weekly limit um
there was a weekly limit prior and that
caused different different issues for
different both members and employers so
the legislature replace that within a
calendar year limit of
1352 with the grandfathering which
averages out to 32 hours a week uh this
provision is 1872 hours in a calendar
year which averages out to 36 hours a
week um we'll point out that there there
is no definition of full-time in our
statute RSA 100a it says you know
full-time permanent positions but we
have administrative rules uh that were
promulgated back in the 90s that put put
hourly limits definitions a definition
of a full-time teacher is regularly
scheduled 30 hours or more a week uh
employee um could be 35 37 and a half or
40 depending on the employer and then
for group two it's as defined by the
employer and that's you know because of
the way the shifts work uh that way so
you know there's a so there there's a by
rule there's a distinction so 36 already
exceeds the um you know the minim
minimum participation standard in the
rule for you know teachers and employees
um so so that's problematic for us you
know our as we've testified in the past
about these bills our only concern about
how much and how how long and and uh
retirees can work after retirement is if
the distinction between part-time and
full-time is is blurred too closely
you'd have people essentially working a
career retiring doing the same job for
two or three hours less a week
collecting a pension from
us since it's it's part-time there would
be no contributions coming in on that
position and it you know if enough of
that those occurrences happen you know
it could collapse upon itself and the
rates would Skyrocket for those with
full-time members so that's you know
that's that's the scenario that that we
always try to put out so i' be glad to
answer any
questions thank you representive
goalie thank thank you madam
share Marty I'm looking at the paper you
handed out I want to make sure I'm
reading this
correctly
So currently you can work up to
1352 hours a year and if I look at your
paper it says the average annual hours
per either police officer or fire police
is 669 which is not even half of what
they could work and fires 488 almost a
third of what they're able to work is am
I reading that correctly you you are
actually I G I brought a copy from
myself for my notes which I gave to
representative McGuire so I don't have
it anymore do you have an extra
copy uh
certainly yeah there should be
one
yes thank you and I had copies made for
the committee because I thought that was
useful
information
so so yeah the the chart you're
referring to this is a report we put
together on the calend calend year 22
hours worked uh the current currently
employers are are reporting the 2023
data you know that's due uh middle of
next month although there sometimes lags
on that so yeah this is yeah the hours
worked for fire yes was um 669 for
police and 488 for fire
average you know
yeah thank
you okay any other questions
representative Dolan
thank you madam chair do do you we
expect to be hearing from nhma for this
bill uh nhma has sent a representative
who is listening if she chooses to
testify I'd be curious to know how what
various municipalities feel about about
this bill if they could tell okay we'll
uh ask her to to report after Mr Carlin
is
through any other
questions thank you very much
thank you chairman Maguire and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Katherine heck and I represent the
new hampster Municipal Association I did
not prepare testimony but we did sign in
opposition to this bill and I'd be Happ
to take questions or
explain our position you have't asked
for an explanation thank you please
please explain okay so I we have decided
to oppose this bill not because we don't
need our part-time retirees to be able
to rejoin our Workforce in some capacity
however based on the number of hours
they'd be allowed to work in the
calendar year it really becomes
full-time work so in looking at um about
20 to 30 of our members Personnel
policies and what they require or Define
as full-time is usually between 32 hours
a week and 37 and a half some even 40
with the average being about 35 hours a
week so basically our local Personnel
policies by virtue of the statute will
become null and void as far as what they
would be eligible for in the retirement
system so we certainly want to preserve
the ability to have part-time work as we
can see from this chart we're not really
seeing the number of retirees um taking
full advantage of what's already on the
books but we also want to be very
careful to preserve the long-term
sustainability of the retirement system
itself and not mandate any new cost to
employers um it would be a local option
if someone chose to allow a retiree
under this bill to work more hours but
then that again would require them to be
part of the retirement system so for for
that reason um we think it's in conflict
with many of our local person Personnel
policies and contracts negotiations that
are already in place thank you are there
further further
questions thank you very much all right
and the last testimony from repres from
Mr bodden Bo bod excuse
me thank you madam chairman again
members of the committee for the record
my name is artha bodri I represent the
New Hampshire State permanent
firefighters retirement
Association and I am here in opposition
of House Bill
um a lot of the smaller departments now
it seems like uh not even smaller
departments some of the bigger
departments are are trying to figure a
way not to pay the retirement system and
they're hiring a retired uh firefighters
from other departments to be their
Chiefs either a chief of police or chief
of the fire department and allegedly
working part-time when it's extremely
difficult if you're a chief of a
department to work part-time if you have
a call in the middle of the night and
your 30 hours or 26 hours are up you're
not going to say well I'm not going to
go to that fire because I had too many
hours in and one of the hats that I used
to wear was I was on the school board in
the city of Manchester and I know
firsthand that it was
egregiously uh work now as far as uh
principles if a principal would leave or
if they were suspended or they were out
for extended uh um sick leave they would
hire uh a retired principal to come in
and take their their position and you
can actually do it if you look at uh
group one uh with 1352 hours uh most
most group one people on the education
side is 180 days at s hours a day that's
13113 hours so you can realistically
retire and work a full-time job and
still be under under the minimum hours
of this bill we have gone on record
every time a bill like this comes up
that we're opposed to it and that it
should be back to an hourly standard
where 20 hours a week is considered
part-time um anything over 30 hours a
week really are eligible for the
Affordable Care Act so do you start uh
giving uh Health Care to these
individuals um so there's a lot of
concerns
with raising the hours and again I'm
repeating myself but I would like to see
it go back to having hours per week we
because you can really get around the
1352 hours when you look at a year
especially again group one uh teachers
with the hours that they have to work
yeah with that I will take any
questions thank you representative Brown
uh thank you madam chair thanks for
taking my question do do you agree with
the the sponsor that this will help to
bring more people to Bear to work as we
as we hear all the time we're short uh
everywhere in the state and and being a
select board member in my town I know we
struggle to fill positions the numbers
prove themselves the num numbers are
showing that we're not getting we're not
getting enough right now under the
existing law so I would say no what it's
going to do is help a few people that
want to retire and become a chief of a
small department and not have to pay
into the retirement system that's that
and it hurts the retirement system
because now you're taking money out of
the unfunded acred liability when you're
not paying into the system
so it's a double-edged
SW thank you very much other
questions all right that's it does
anyone else wish to testify on House
Bill
1299 seeing none I'll close the hearing
open the hearing on House Bill 1421 and
call Representative
Pearson not any
good afternoon for the record
Representative Steve Pearson Rockingham
District 13 which encompasses
Dairy let me uh let me paint a picture
of what's going on right
now so right now the the Hampshire
retirement
system has this gigantic chunk of money
it's 11 almost 11 and a half billion
dollars and they take that money and
they entrust it to a
firm whose job it
is to follow the instructions of their
investment
committee which is over an
overall
Target and their job is to invest the
money currently retirement benefits it's
roughly 80% of retirement benefits come
out of the employees current paychecks
the other 20% comes through the
investment
process as you will learn as a member of
this committee because you will see it
what the
Investments returns are reports are
filed we got a great little pamphlet
that's published that shows it going
back a number of
years but what happens is that money is
invested through one
outfit an outfit that is paid
a humongous amount of money to implement
and manage the Investments That 11.5
billion
do and to provide returns that are
within a targeted
framework to maintain the
system but this firm gets paid no matter
what we could have an 18% % return we
could have a -6% return it really does
not
matter so what has been
done
elsewhere is they've said okay wait a
minute here since there's no incentive
to perform perhaps we
should put this into a situation where
there is incentive to
perform so what this bill does is it
says we're going to take the the assets
of the pension system the 115 billion
dollars of assets and we're going to
have two firms do it and those firms are
going to compete against each
other because now there is incentive to
perform and if you fail if you are the
lesser of the two your contract is not
renewed and it it opens it up for
bidding for other firms to come
in and the firm that did perform the
best is is
renewed this is not a concept I
invented the state of Missouri does this
of course their assets are substantially
larger than ours but as a as a much
larger state but the idea is the
same that I feel without an incentive to
perform are we really getting the work
we're paying for and I'll give you a
great example when I sat on this
committee
during
covid the
chairman not the chairman the the the
representative of the investment
committee came before this before Edna
and I asked the simple question during
covid when the
market had a downward track it didn't
plummet but it had a downward track what
moves did you make with the assets of
that system to protect it while this was
occurring the answer we received was
nothing we did
nothing you can watch that testimony on
YouTube and I'm going to apologize for
the way I responded to him ahead of time
because I was not gentle that was
inexcusable that a managed investment of
assets nearly the size of our state
budget were pretty much non-man
they
spectated that cannot happen we don't
pay for that it's not within the
fiduciary benefit of this system and it
certainly does not
help getting us out of the debt that the
system is under so I think this concept
would at least bring
into this area some
competition and would force the firms to
actually
manage the assets of our system for the
money that we pay them to
do I'll be happy to take questions thank
you and I see represent of black has one
already uh thank you um so I mean you
looked at Missouri my question is I'm
not um opposed to necessarily the plan
you have but have you looked at what
other states are doing to provide um
some kind of incentive or competition or
something are there other ways that this
is handled other than what we're doing
which is one firm and that's it I mean
there are there are we got 50 states
there's 50 plans I have not gone state
byst state to look at this um you know
given the fact that we are a relatively
small state and we're looking at
a very small area of firms that would
handle something of this magnitude
I think two is a reasonable way to go I
think going beyond that is going to get
complicated and and difficult to even
attract enough firms
but but the that's where the the two
basically comes from like I said the
state of Missouri do using two follow up
just brief I was thinking more of
something different like uh their
compensation being based on return or
something like that so performance-based
contract is what
I mean that's certainly a concept that
is would be acceptable to me right
because again we're entrusting these
guys with
a like I said it's almost the budget of
the state that's a substantial amount of
money here so okay again we're looking
we're looking to get the best return we
can out of these Investments without
risking the farm right
so I don't you know
with the free market principle and and
competition
being a principle of at least my party's
fiscal conservatism I I think that th
This falls right in line with that thank
you I agree with that position but okay
repres
Gard thank you madam
chair so recently I was watching Tucker
Carlson on Twitter but he interviewed
The Wolf of Wall Street oh sure the real
guy let's pull his name up Belfor and
some interesting things came about that
I think is pertinent to this sit uh
conversation so he was discussing mutual
funds and other fund managers hedge
funds and so forth and the thieves they
derive from what they do then they get
performance bonuses and what I didn't
realize is index traded funds so let's
say the S&P 500 the 500 strongest
companies Etc they on year after year it
has a 10
12% gain so just owning a slice of all
those companies which as far as I
understand doesn't really require a
manager my point being is can we forgo
all of this and simply have some kind of
do you know I'm trying to get at I don't
understand why we need these managers
who taking all the fees off the top and
yeah I get exactly what you're
saying I am responsible for the lives of
people on a fire engine I am not a
financial adviser not even close I you
know I I I did okay with a little bit of
er trade work you know last year but
certainly not to handle the assets of
our pension system so that that's that's
a question for that's a much deeper
question that really would have to be
handled by by the Retirement Systems
board of directors and their financial
people and that I get what you're saying
believe me the the a market index right
is a great thing to compare your what
you're doing versus is you know S&P 500
being one of them and there are several
others but the reality today and and you
you guys will for those of you are in
Edna for the first time when you get
this report they break down how the
performance in various categories okay
one of the things that is that to me is
kind of like it's kind of a wow moment
is the fact that you can get I can get
CDs in the upper sixes right now okay
the all all we need to to for the
retirement system to hit its minimum
goal is 6.75 when you have a 11 billion
dollars of assets you can actually get
CD rates that are higher than seven
that's zero management and zero
risk okay so we need to kind of relook
at this a little bit here and I think
that getting a second set of eyes Beyond
The Firm that we've used for the last 25
years and get some fresh blood going on
here maybe can can shake this thing up a
little bit thank you I'd like to mention
mentioned that ex officio I received the
report from the board of the retirement
system and I have a copy in the office
if anybody wants to read it it's very uh
interesting reading it's got all the
details representative Brown uh thank
you madam chair um so excuse me uh since
I'm new to this whole process is there a
problem first question well okay so
we have an index I don't agree with the
number we use at 6.75 but that's that is
The Benchmark okay that the retirement
system uses to say this is what we need
to run the show we base our
[Music]
employer responsibilities based on that
and every two years we're we reevaluate
what we charge the municipalities a lot
of that is based on two things one
little tweaks and wiggles by the
legislature but even more so by the
investment return coming off of
these that really drives where these
employer rates go so
having good investment returns with the
system of payoff we're currently
under will drive Municipal rates down it
does not shorten the duration of our
debt that's a whole another argument as
to why we shouldn't have done it that
way but that's how we're doing it so
that's the driving factor for municipal
rates the better we do in Investments
the lower the municipal rates will be
and I.E the cost to the taxpayer so the
idea that this firm can pretty much go
hey here's the rate shut up and pay me
which is really the function that we're
under right now to me is just not we've
got to break from that we've got to
break from that
mold thank followup
uh it's a different question actually M
better um
uh is this a process that happens
anywhere else in the state Contracting
system now I know that for example there
might be three Hazmat contractors hired
for task because one of them isn't
enough to handle the cases so are there
any other situations in the state of New
Hampshire where this competitive process
happens the only institution in the
state of New Hampshire that is insane
enough to entrust itself because of its
size is the state
budget it's the only thing in New
Hampshire that's larger than the
Holdings of the pension system so I
think in this particular case we we in
require 425 people to interject in the
state budget I think maybe we need more
than one firm interjecting in an 11
billion doll pension system thank
okay representative
Bailey I don't know how likely it is but
I can imagine that the first two
investment firms you pick are the best
and then everybody else is the rest and
you're comparing the two and the second
one gets dropped out in favor of the
rest the second one would get dropped
out and then the the process to bid for
that job would would begin every four
years your someone's drop it someone's
losing so if you're if you're actively
managing this which is what we're paying
a firm to do if you're actively managing
this and you do well and you're very
good at it you might be the one of the
two firms for the next 50 years that's
great but if you fail to
to do this job that we've entrusted you
with and you're not
performing then we're not we're not
interested in you anymore we're going to
get somebody else in here that's willing
to actually manage and care about the
performance return and not just hold do
what they do and get a nice sizable fee
from the retirees mind you that pay for
this or the active members is what I
should say in retire is that that's
where the money comes from to pay for
this firm it comes out of my paycheck
really thank you thank you
representative
Gart something you just said caught my
attention so what
stops uh individual or firm that loses a
contract from creating some shell
Corporation somewhere and then rebidding
isn't this just a game of shell it's a
shell game no we have the first of all
the Secretary of State's office I'm
gonna give them a little bit more credit
than that okay these the the investment
firms that would even begin to tackle
something of this quantity are run
National TV commercials they are known
entities this is not Joe's investment
firm that he runs out the back of his
gas station the this you know what I'm
saying so is Enron I mean you know I
yeah sorry so so again we have the the
Hampshire retirement system has a board
of directors they have an entire
Financial advisory committee they are
tasked with making sure
that there's no this is not a shell game
I mean that's that is their fiduciary
responsibility right now okay thank you
okay other questions for representative
Pearson thank you very much you're
welcome Mr
Carlin thanks again Mr um Madam chair uh
Marty Carlin representing
nhrs um board has not currently taken a
position on this bill uh they may be
looking at it next month um as
representative Pierce mentioned Pearson
rep mentioned this morning we do tend to
talk a lot on the phone but we we
actually haven't spoken about this bill
and there are a couple of um
misconceptions I I'd like to start by
kind of clearing up with so the way the
process works is um you know our
our we have a Board of Trustees and they
are casted in stat
as fiduciaries they set an asset
allocation hire a consultant and um get
you know reports on from the Independent
investment committee the in independent
investment committee was created by
Statute in 2009 to oversee the the ma
the right the management of the fund and
the individual managers in the fund
prior to that it was the board uh
picking you know one one manager over
another um type of thing so the iic has
been around for 15 years now they are
required by law to have experience in
institutional investment or Public
Finance so um you know over the years
we've been able to draw um you know
folks from you know retirees from some
of the larger you know puam investment
type firms CEOs things like that uh
private private wealth managers you know
with their own businesses so they're
they're the folks who are over seeing
you know the pieces of the portfolio uh
we have a small in-house investment
staff as a director of Investments and
and three people who work uh for him
sort of monitoring the managers we're
not buying and selling out of nhrs and
all of all of our uh assets are
externally managed our staff sort of
keeps an eye on the managers and and
things like that and we also hire an
investment consultant and that's that's
what representative Pearson was talking
about right currently it's a firm called
Kalen Associates uh they're a national
firm there's a you know in in like in
any sector there's a a number of um
investment Consultants that work with
State County City pension plans
endowments University yeah things like
that um Ken is one of them we hired them
um after an RFP process in either 2019
or 20 I don't have the date right in
front of me this is a this consulting
position is something that goes out to
RFP um on a minimum of a fiveyear window
uh we had had a consultant
nepc again another National firm that
had been with us um probably for 10 or
15 years before that and in in the RFP
process uh the last time it went through
Ken won the hearts of the investment
committee and the board um you know over
the incumbent so so we do switch and and
the consultant
doesn't manage the money we don't just
push it across the table and say you go
with it the the consultant is is is what
it sounds like it's a consultant uh they
will assist internal staff with vetting
uh different investment strategies and
different investment managers uh doing
due diligence on you know potential
investment opportunities and give their
provide their reports to the investment
committee staff Also may do their own
diligence and make a recommendation so
we don't have one the 11 billion isn't
like you know there's one person in a
you know in a CL Tower smoking a cigar
doing our money you know we we work we
have dozens of managers under that
umbrella we have fixed income managers
we have private Equity managers we have
a real estate consultant we have public
Equity Funds managers that we invest
with so you know and it's a diverse
portfolio so there's the large cap
stocks you know the you know the big
five that are driving the market surge
lately midsize companies small companies
public non publicly traded companies you
know are in the private Equity piece um
fixed income includes bonds you know and
other you know public and um private
credit around the in the US and around
the world so there's a lot of different
consultants and you know the investment
committee's job is to you know work you
know they recommend an allocation to the
board and then they then the board the
board is comfortable with that
allocation right now it's 50% equities
20% fixed income 15 real estate and 15
alts if that adds up to 100 but um you
know they're looking for you know
diversification in the portfolio so if
you're all all going into growth stocks
and it's a bare Market you you're going
to lose your shirt so you want to have
you know H hedge your bets not hedge
funds we don't do those but um good
goodness know um you know but but but
have that diversification of a portfolio
and and both the board and the
investment Committee in their actions
are fiduciaries and that that means
under law they they have to act in the
best interests of the plan participants
they're basically managing this money
for someone else you know they're
Trustees of of this amount so they they
have to be careful with what they uh you
know where they choose what they choose
to put the money in and um at least you
know if you know not you know the
markets are fickle and sometimes even
the best looking Investments don't
perform the way you want but that we
have a process in place you know where
steps in due diligence are taking so
that you know the decisions meet the
standard of what what a prudent person
with the requisite background and
knowledge due in that situation that's
that's that's part of the fiduciary
standard in our statute so you know
there there's no uh you know plug-and
play type of thing all of the individual
managers for instance if we if I don't I
didn't bring the breakdown here but you
know we have diff you know in in small
cap stocks which are you know smaller
publicly traded companies you know we
probably have a couple of managers in
that sector and they may have different
strategies they you know they may not
but um you know and all of these
individual managers are under a contract
with us and we do pay a fee um you know
as an Institutional Investor our fees
are less than a private investor would
have to pay or you know 401K fee you
know we you know there's a there's a
standard and Poor 500 you know passive
fund uh that we invest in and we're
paying less than one basis point on a
you know $3 billion piece you know so we
have some passive Investments and we
have some actively managed Investments
and those have to perform better than
the markets over a period of time or
they're not worth you know paying for
the additional uh people who who are
actively managing that so these
contracts have been on a three-year
cycle uh you know with you know in with
you know when they come in and you know
why should we stick with you and you
know the committee can opt to review
them we have the opportunity to pull out
at any point but you know if if we want
to reup with them you know three some
some we've done on a five-year basis but
you know there there's um you know if
there there's something you know the you
know the Brain Trust of a particular
fund all you know left to go somewhere
else or walked Walked Away From The Firm
we could pull out of that you know you
know in a and it's not like it's you can
pull out in a day you know there's a lot
to untangle there and with Market timing
there's a lot of
uh issues where you you can't um you
know it's going to cost you more money
to do this on Tuesday than it is next
Tuesday so you know we need to be
prudent as fiduciaries in terms of the
timing of these things so you know
there's a lot goes on I I
remember vaguely you know the U exchange
representative Pearson talked about on
YouTube and it it's not I think you know
have not seen the clip I think I think
the answer was we didn't do anything
because we're long-term invest and there
are going to be dips in markets and you
know we it's a battleship not a you know
a PT Boat you can't turn it on a dime um
you know because because of the scope of
the plan and the obligation so certainly
the individual managers and the staff
were
um uh following the markets during the
pandemic and certainly those first
couple months that really coked us
because it was in the fourth quarter of
the fiscal year but had we
moved dramatically away from that
portfolio we would have lost the 29%
gain in the following fiscal year you
know when when markets began to correct
and most of that was in the second half
of that year so you know the there's you
know investment performance is very
endpoint dependent you know you can look
at any segment and you could look like a
genius or a fool but move it over a
couple of months and and you know it's
more neutral uh last year um we our
return was
8.2% um that actually trailed our
benchmark Mark which was uh over
9% over the three-year period it was a
9.6 return which exceeded the Benchmark
of
7.4% 5ye was 7.1 little bit over the
Benchmark 10 year was 7.9 which was The
Benchmark and then 25 years it was it's
six and a half I think so you know we we
as much as we want to have you know good
week good month good quarter the the
committee and doesn't invest that way
they're investing on the Long Haul
so so um right now Ken is the consultant
you know they attend all of the monthly
meetings and and provide reports and
updates and and statistical analysis and
things like that for us for that we pay
them $660,000 a year in the contract so
under this bill we'd be we would hire a
kalon equivalent I guess you know and
our former consultant NPC which is a
fine firm if they were both doing this
research and recommendation and vetting
you know you know people don't call the
investment director and say hey I got a
deal for you you know you know we click
we hang up on those and we said funnel
them through the consultant to vet you
know who's legitimate and what's what's
the track record and then they'll pair
down a list you know for the investment
committee to interview so so there is a
process in place so um you know so
there's a concern on as a fiduciary of a
redundancy with the work they're doing
and paying somebody a similar amount to
do essentially the same work if they
recommend different managers is that we
going to be making smaller Investments
and more managers you know arguably some
people may say that's a good thing or
not but you know there there's an
economy of of scale with working this
way so and K and also we could if
something egregious happened with them
we could walk away but that's a
five-year contract on their end so
that's kind of the backlog um you know
the highlights of you kind of want to to
cover I'll be glad to answer any
questions okay thank you representative
Shu thank you madam chair um I actually
have a couple questions uh you mentioned
uh a three-year contract cycle where are
we right now in that contract on the
individual managers you know they they
get hired in different months and in
different years so there's there's you
know there's re-ups you know you know
one or two managers are coming up every
C quarter you know they it's not it's
not an all or not you know it's it's
rolling and my next question um
realizing that it's basically up to the
individual investment committee to
direct the
Consultants as to the amount of risk
that they want to put forward on behalf
of the system um would it not be their
responsibility to judge uh whatever
firms were talking about in this bill
rather than the actual Board of of
Trustees yeah they they they do they
they're they're The Gatekeepers for that
the the that Authority was taken from
the full Board of Trustees invested in
the investment committee back in 09 and
that committee is not all board members
it's not a subcommittee of the board
It's actually an independent investment
committee there are two board members
put on by the chair and there are three
public members and then there's an
active member of the retirement system
who who sits on the committee uh as a
non- voting member so so they meet
um probably you know nine to 8 to 12
times a year you know uh and and in each
besides besides interviewing potential
investment managers or doing contract
re-ups they also get you know updates on
the different segments you know so
there's a couple time like July and
December you know or June and December
the real estate consultant comes in they
go over a deeper dive into that
portfolio fixed income you know every
six months you know they they're
reviewing them every month but it's a
deeper dive and then occasionally
because you know we're large enough you
know not you know there's a lot bigger
plans but you know with 11 billion you
know we can get you know the you know
the research director to come down from
their their tower in New York City and
come talk to the you know the board
about Capital Market expectations or
what the Ukraine war is doing to markets
and what that's looking like so they can
get that kind of just you know input you
know from from experts in in different
areas of
finance representative leus thank you
I'm just uh going to ask for some
information you know for you to to get
for the committee and that is um you
know what what have been the returns
each year for you know going back as far
as you reasonably can and also list with
that um what are the major indexes been
for those years and then if you could
take and group them like every five
years averages in maybe 10 years might
make sense but uh so we're not just uh
freaking out because it's different for
one year um and that information is in
the retirement system reports and Mr
Carlin gave a summary of the last one
year five year 10 years just a few
minutes are those the reports you
mentioned that we have here okay thank
you
great represent man py thank you madam
chair just a clarification question your
investment uh Comm
there are five Members Plus One non
voting member yes thank you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much
thanks is there anyone else who wishes
to testify on House Bill
1421 those seeing none close the hearing
and open the hearing on House Bill
1307 I believe that's representative
Damon here
good
afternoon I am chair Maguire committee
members and public I'm representative
hope Damon I serve Sullivan District 8
which are the beautiful sugar river
towns of are you ready aworth Langdon
lemster Goan Springfield Washington s my
hometown of Cen and the City of
Claremont I serve on the education and
housing committees I'm here today to
introduce House Bill 1307 which was
developed following a constituent
request the bill does two things first
it provides a one-time supplemental
allowance to members of the retirement
system who are receiving an accidental
disability retirement allowance and
retired before achieving 20 years of
service second it provides for future
supplemental allowances and cost of
living ad adjustments for these same
accidental disability beneficiaries to
be granted without regard to years of
credible
service Robert Mory of cin is one of a
small group of disability retirees who
sered less than 20 years and so have not
been eligible for recent colas or
one-time bonuses Bob served 19 and a
half years pretty darn close to 20 but
there's a line in the sand working as an
EMT and firemen in several Upper Valley
communities mainly
Handover he trained many people and
saved many lives Bob was injured in a
fall on the job that broke his back in
five places eventually after numerous
evaluations and treatments and more than
one unsuccessful attempt to return to
work the injury led to his reluctant
retirement on disability he was informed
by his neurologist and back specialist
that continuing to work would result in
even more severe pain and probable
complete loss of
Mobility Bob and his wife Julie very
much wanted to attend this hearing today
and speak directly with you but most
unfortunately his back and feet Agony
from the injury causing his disability
prohibits him traveling from croon to
conquered he is tortured by the reality
that he can no longer do things like
this Bob like many of our valued
Emergency Services professionals rescued
saved lives taught and mentored troubl
teens and in every way he could could
serve the citizens of New Hampshire he
gave his life to his profession and was
passionate about it it was not his plan
to leave the work he loved and was good
at it's time for the State of New
Hampshire retirement system to provide
colas and bonuses to these folks on
disability whenever they are awarded to
20-year
retirees the average income of group two
retired firefighters in New Hampshire is
about
$45,000 95% make less than
$50,000 Mr Moran's retirement benefit he
retired in 1989 I believe is slightly
under
$30,000 as I'm sure you are all well
aware that is an inade income for any
reasonable standard of living
here the average cost of living in New
Hampshire in 2023 was $
56,7
127 the state median income is
$83,400
in The Last 5 Years annual Social
Security cost of living adjustments have
ranged from
1.3% to
8.7% this bill does not attempt to match
those just to provide a little financial
help to our valued
retirees the bill as drafted caps these
benefits to retirees receiving less than
$40,000
annually as you see in the fiscal note
the cost of this well-deserved
compensation is $41 $1,000 as there are
802 individuals who would be eligible
this is a very small sum in the context
of our banal budget and the existing
Surplus you will hear testimony from
Arthur bowry who is president of the New
Hampshire State permanent firefighters
professional retirement
Association and he will speak to if the
cap is raised to $50,000 that will more
fully recognize those in need because as
noted
95% of the group two retired
firefighters earn or are receiving less
than $50,000 a
year um I would appreciate the
opportunity to amend the bill
accordingly when it was drafted I did
not have that U piece of
information so I respectfully urge the
committee to vote OTP on this simple
effort to slightly ease the financial
challenges of retirees who dedicated
many years to our well-being I thank you
for your consideration
and I'm happy to try to answer questions
if there are
some are there any
questions I don't see any thank you very
much for your testimony thank you for
your time and your work I'm sorry oops
represent Simon does have a question
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um course what was
the uh why $500 in particular how did
you arrive at that
number no particular reason just a place
to start okay I believe that was
approximately the last one-time payment
we gave to retirees okay yes that is
that is true thank you
chair all right thank you very much for
your testimony Mr Carlin you've got some
numbers for
us thank you madam chair again Marty
Carlin for your retirement system the
retirement system doesn't have a
position on this bill I did um re
representative Damon reached out to me
and we discussed this several months ago
so I understand the constituent issue
involved and and um just just uh again
to kind sort of back it up a little bit
I mean uh disability annuitants are
eligible for one-time payments or colas
however last year uh we end up being in
house bill to I forget what what the
original Bill had started in there was a
$500 payment for retire has retired more
than 5 years so that would be July 1 of
18 uh or before uh making less than
40,000 a year um they would um receive
this and and had 20 years of service
when they 20 years or more when they
retired so that language adding the 20
years to that specific one-time payment
did pull out any you know disability
inuent who was injured and able to
complete more than 20 years or more um
that that is in a regular occurrence
there was a
2018 $500 payment that also had a
20-year limit on it and that that one
actually had an even another slip up in
it as well that we identified in um you
know for future reference is it it said
me it said retirees it didn't address
beneficiary so survivors didn't get that
$500 and um so that you know I I
wouldn't say it's an oversight on either
the legislature Insurance's part where
applying the law is written but when you
start putting in other triggers between
you know when you're retired or how much
you're making people can fall through
the cracks and that's what happened last
year this the language in the current
bill if it's not amended mirrors the
qualifications for the uh last year's
$500 payment so this cohort which I
think we estimated is about 800 people
who would be eligible so that's $400,000
for
$500 um you know would get that that
one-time payment uh after the bill
passes uh and the the language also adds
a provision to the statute that
would prevent an oversight in the future
unless the legislature otherwise
specified that people with less than 20
years are getting it regardless it would
it would just carry over for those folks
so uh that's just kind of the background
you know back in the 80s and '90s and
2000s you know cers were a percentage
permanent increase to the pension and
everybody got the same one uh in the
member group as as um funding got tied
and there were you know there's only one
Cola since 2010 but these $500 payments
have been issued periodically and in
different years the legislature has had
different Criterion and different
ceilings for how much somebody's going
to get I can I can send over to the
committee the sort of a 25 year history
of the these payments just for reference
if you if you if you want um but you
know that's that's that's where this is
this this is where all that all came
from and um representative had spoken
and Mr bodry had reached out to me
earlier this week about if the cap for
this group was increased to $50,000 that
would add approximately 70 to 80 more
people to this so that's another you
know 35 to
40,000 this appropriation would be a
general fund appropriation by the state
to to pay this benefit in this in the
bill so glad to answer any questions
that would how many people between 40
and 50 uh approximately 70 to 80 and and
you know we're we're dealing with you
know end of fiscal year numbers from
June may have lost some of those folks
um you know by the time you know the
process winds
out thank you I didn't quite catch that
other uh other questions representative
Simon thank you madam chair uh Mr K do
you you know uh are the disability
benefits
taxable um The Accidental which is a job
related disability those are non-
taxable and um you know the the uh
ordinary or non-job related uh benefits
are taxable I I honestly don't know what
the five how the $500 would apply for
taxation because it's not part of the
pension it's a one-time payment so I'm
thinking that would be taxable could
could you find out for me yeah thank
you okay other other uh
questions I had one I heard a report I'm
not sure where that half the group two
retirees were on disability pensions is
that correct or was I totally
misinformed that that that is incorrect
um I uh the other representative Maguire
asked me the same question this morning
ah and I I I scroll down some notes from
the our annual report that I wrote on my
phone um um and it it looks like of uh
for group two there's
4764 total police
retirees and both job related and
non-job related there
4177 disability notes so less than 10%
uh I was totally misinformed yeah and
much less 132 out of 1900 for fire so
even lower percentage I'm so glad to
hear about
it all right does anyone else have any
rumors to be verified
or all right thank you um thank you for
your testimony Mr
bodri thank you madam chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is ala bodri I represent the New
Hampshire State permanent fire fighter
retirement Association and I'm here to
speak in favor of House Bill 1307 and uh
I just want to clarify um the
representative mentioned professional
firefighters I represent the permanent
firefighters um and uh we are here in
favor of it and again the these are
members who didn't choose to retire um
or to get injured for that matter they
they had to retire due to a job related
injury and most of these injuries that
at least firefighters you know if they
they like um the representative
mentioned you know you hurt your back
if you if you're gaining income because
of Physical Agility or ability and then
you lose that your income is definitely
diminished and I I can't reiterate
enough that group two does not receive
Social Security and that's a huge thing
so these people that are going out on
disability they may not be able to
obtain another job but also they don't
have so security to fall back on either
um so over the last decade uh the cost
of living based on a CPI has gone up
approximately 20 29.3 3% while col is
granted to group two police and
firefighters over the same time period
were 1 and a half% over the last 20
years cost of living has gone up by 64.5
3% while col is granted to group two
police and fire over the same time
period were
12.25% and 15%
respectfully um that is over uh TW that
over
52% uh of the pensioners buying power
has been eliminated due to inflation and
the lack of adequate cers the permanent
firefighters had legislation submitted
uh had legislation submitted for a cola
last year and again the bill was changed
in the Senate finance committee instead
of a cola a stien was granted for those
members making less than
$40,000 and it included group one that
change partic uh practically eliminated
a large group group of group two members
as I stated before group two
firefighters average pension is
approximately
$45,000 social security has uh given its
members an 8.7% increase in
2023 and went uh up again this year at
3.2% unfortunately group two police and
fire don't receive Social Security um
the average pension for a group two
police officer is approximately
$40,000 and the average for
uh firefighter is approximately
$45,000 so if you were to raise or
change amend the bill to go to 50,000 as
uh Mr Collins stated it bring in another
70 to 80 members and uh 95% of the
members make less than $50,000 a year
and that is not a lot of money to live
on um you know taxes are going up uh
electric electricity is going up gas is
going up um it uh it doesn't take much
to erode your pension so uh if people
think 50,000 is a lot um come and
liveing summer
worth okay thank you are there any
questions representa Simon and then
representative man thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question um just
for clarification purposes the average
pension has been mentioned several times
um when we're talking average pension
are we talking across to all pensioners
meaning all number all years of service
all you know um are we talking about you
know some people were 10 years some
people 20 years some people with 30
years experience because it will
obviously greatly affect the average
that's right the average from my
understanding and Marty correct me if
I'm wrong if there's a thousand retired
firefighters the average is going to be
$45,000 for that thousand firefighter
regardless of number of years served or
anything like that okay thank you
yeah person Man Booty thank you madam
chair just to clar another clarification
the 70 to 80
people after the ceiling of 40 to 50,000
has increased right yes so the total
number of uh
retirees or um retirees with the
disability yes that we are looking at is
total number is 70 to 80 people the
total number would be 800 because the
original number brought in 800 and I
think it was
8002 82 Sophia let's go with the high in
if you add another 80 it'll be 882 okay
for a total okay other questions
represent
lus um so just to to clarify something
um so let's say you've been a
firefighter your whole career you've
never paid in a social security are you
Avail are you eligible for federal
disability uh benefits that to be honest
with you I don't know I don't recall any
any firefighters that I've represented
have gone on a federal of disability
it's always spend the retirement system
that's their main source of income all
right thank you other
questions okay thank you very much for
Testimony does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill
1307 not seeing anybody I'm going to
close the public hearing the
subcommittee will be scheduling a
meeting at its earliest convenience and
I'll see you all next week
um
that